i'm uh about to go through changes but
i'm doing all right did is it because
you ate something
i don't know we'll find amica
eating smoking two chocolates and we got
some liquid acid on sugar cubes he might
have to eat later that's awesome look at
this [ __ ] we got this [ __ ] liquid
acid
we got the box of sugar cubes
i i've never [ __ ] since i was a kid
you did something where it was like
yeah and you put it on your skin that's
to say all this [ __ ] is like [ __ ]
cutting edge now these young kids
this shit's [ __ ] crazy
they brought it to a show this guy comes
to my shows every 90 days
yeah that's good yeah he brings me
chocolate covered mushrooms with thc
chocolate he grinds down the mushrooms
i don't know where i like i i you can't
talk about this online
the [ __ ] joey this month lee get him in
control this guy grinds up the mushrooms
gets the chocolate puts the thc in it
and it's like a chocolate
mushroom
no no no no
these young college kids now they're
about to change the [ __ ] did you have a
sugar cube lee not tonight and i've had
about what for sure yeah we got a couple
guys you know what i always thought was
the bummer about acid was that
you like
if i if i'm planning a weekend say
and i go well friday night's coming i'd
like to get high on acid and but then
also saturday is right behind it and i
want to get high on acid you got to take
a half a hit like a blotter acid and
then you got to take a hit or a hit and
a half just to get off on it
and it's never as good you feel dopey
with it right i got blotted too joey's
never taken half
start this [ __ ] thing we got
everything we could even put a drop on
the bladder
he says like if you got that and say
it's 100
cc's 100 milligrams right he says so
then you cut it in force
and take a quarter hit every day or
something like that
and so like that's how you you want to
know how much your
acid is dosed but like and then you get
i don't know i don't know
everybody's talking about all that kind
of no no i think it's a little bit less
than a quarter i think it's like
supposed to be like almost nothing it
depends on your [ __ ] but like 12 and a
half milligrams to 20 no more than 25
milligrams tate we had
like what 500 tonight something like
that we don't have five million we do we
go deep tape we went like no no i mean
i've acid oh that's not yes he sees this
[ __ ] he tells me when he gives it to me
lee's already lost oh yeah he's he's
going through changes listen who knows
anyways this show is brought to you by
this show is presented by on it
the church of what's happening now is
brought to you by zeal and i can't guys
i can't tell you how much i love zeal it
was my first massage
it was the best experience i could have
hoped for go check them out zeal.com or
they have an iphone and android app and
it's zeal z-e-e-l
and when you go to zeel.com ad click add
promo code and enter code church and you
get 25 off of your first massage that's
zeal.com
promo code church to get 25 off the days
are back the church of what's happening
now and lisa and myself
i'm very proud to introduce you to
hellotushy.com
hellotushy.com makes portable devices
you could bring this on the road with
you if you wanted to and i would
recommend it go to hellotushy.com get
these portable devices that spray your
butt clean with water
when you go to hellotushy.com church you
get 10 off of your order that's
hellotoshi.com
church i might need one of those you do
come by the house i got an extra for you
awesome here we go [ __ ] crank
that little puerto rican
where's trump
oh [ __ ]
wednesday march 1st
here we go [ __ ] get those
[ __ ] cockroach killers on the puerto
ricans are coming oh [ __ ]
of what's happening now
my man tate fletcher
my little jewish goomba lisa
and your uncle joey [ __ ]
having you bad [ __ ] uncle joey
here on a ho-hum wednesday night
thursday morning
welcoming you to podcastville my main
man tate
and little lee over there [ __ ] going
through changes already and [ __ ] the
show hasn't even kicked in yet there's
la luna's getting me yeah i can tell a
little let's get you because you don't
need them at that you know this
[ __ ]
on the weekend tate hold me back right
now
hold on
take a lead don't [ __ ] around
train on the weekends
eat these edibles on the weekends and
you would come on the show and we go
deep you don't get [ __ ] up
so he goes online i could see him that
he's eating the chocolates but he's not
making faces
when he eats chocolate he don't like
chocolate so if he eats chocolate he'll
make a face and the thc he'll start
when he's at home he eats the chocolate
i watch him on periscope and he's joking
around i'm like something ain't right no
i know you so i was looking at him the
other day and what he does is he gets a
hershey bar and he cuts it down the
middle and he opens the bag it's re
closing i'm gonna see you for slander
and he puts it in there and then he eats
it in front of these young kids and
they're like oh well he's going how dare
you he ain't going deep he eats three
stars and gives his girlfriend three
stars how dare you
and then that's the end of the [ __ ]
night he tells everybody's eating twelve
he ain't doing that he's eating 302
hershey bars first of all i'm gonna have
to start doing it at the dispensary to
clear my name i go in there i have not
once
pulled the fast one that's that's that's
your level that's what you were saying
earlier with the with the labels notice
what i'm saying i started it i'm not mad
at you for doing it i'm just saying that
i would never dwell on you almost got
sick before yeah i heard we wait the
first piece of chocolate you're gagging
it's kind of like saying you're a navy
seal if you're not a navy seal what do
you mean saying that you're eating that
much but you're not really yeah he's
lucky cause then he comes out on monday
he comes here on mondays i give him
chocolate he breaks apart he's sweating
he's turning red
so he's doing something funny at home
with the chocolate might not be
hershey's what's going on at the
chocolate at home nothing's going with
it out here
if you guys watch the periscopes
joey if i i get like 26 seconds to eat
the edibles because i don't know if joey
chews them he just is able to swallow
them whole i can't do that i have to
chew if you watch on the periscope i
don't let it touch my tongue because i
hate the taste so i chew it and i keep
it and i do it real slow it takes about
two minutes and i do it fine but here
that's why i puked that one time because
you're just like swallow it
and i tried to swallow an entire
chocolate bar like all chewed up in my
mouth and i puked
all right we gotta watch it from now
that periscope from that i'm gonna show
the brand i always show the brand i'm
sure we look at the old ones i'm gonna
see hershey's kisses it's like when you
cheek one of your pills when you're in
the psych ward
i i
i have no experience with that but
i'm sure what jesus christ
he used to take labels and switch them
on me and then and then not even that
i'm the cheaper shoes yeah not even just
the labels i'm sure i asked him every
time i'm sure you just made it up he at
a certain point he just stopped telling
me he'd be like what it has don't don't
worry about that like he would just
start lying eventually he he wouldn't
even lie at the end he would just say
they used to give they used to have two
types of stuff
they used to have these one and i can't
remember now because it's been like a
year
one time
i had ari coming out and he's like ari
intelligent israel the whole thing is
intelligent israel yeah the whole thing
you know i'm gonna be watching you i
don't trust you
so i went over to the store
and what i did was they had regular
chocolate regular stars for like 125
milligrams
but they had rock candy
that was the same company but only 25
milligrams
so i took the rock candy out of the rock
candy bag and put the stars in there
so even after harry came to me and said
let me look at him he read it and i'm
like he's going to catch that it's hard
rock candy he didn't catch it he goes
okay i'll eat one there only he got so
fixated on the milligrams that's all
histograms that's all he saw so
then i took him deep him that's why
you're a wizard you're like a warlock i
used to give him 180 milligram cheaper
shoes but i'd take the label and put 70
on it and just give him half
so he thought he was eating 35 but he
was really 90. why [ __ ] with that you
know what i'm saying
i know lee if he says i keep eating he's
going to get nervous on the milligram
because he's got his head tripping him
people getting yeah so you use your
warlock skills to do like uh
you do like situational blindness on
people sure so you can help them sure
yeah
you're you're welcome i appreciate it
now i can do 1500 and i i have never
once stolen valor like that like that
those terrible people
stolen weed valor that's what it's
called have you ever had that at your
jiu jitsu school what's that like
someone coming in pretending to be a
black belt no it's a hundred percent
solvable in about 30 seconds or i have
seen videos of it it's great but you
just know i mean it's like there's no
lies on the mat it's what it is why
would somebody come in and do something
it's weird people misguided they don't
know anything there's a guy i was
training with this morning and he was uh
he was uh uh just drop drop in wanted to
be around certain guys or that whatever
and he
i was like oh this is all oh and i i
wearing a ghee like i hadn't had a
guillotine in you know eight year long
time and uh so i just got a gi on in my
my hawaiian board shorts
and um and no belt and then he saw
whatever and and i said oh sure i'll
drill with you and
i was like well this i want you to tuck
your knee up in here no no yeah i got a
and he's one of those i got it guys and
you can tell when you feel with somebody
that you you go oh they don't have any
experience you know they're and which
isn't a bad thing it's just what it is
but the bad thing is when
i'm so [ __ ] up that i got to pretend
like i have some experience you know you
can pretend you're a kickboxer maybe
you're great on mitz or whatever but you
don't know what it's like to be in a
scrap and that's cool too whatever
whatever but like you can't hide from
jiu jitsu you know what i mean it's like
because you're going to get strangled or
people know and i i don't know what i
don't know in this day and age what it
is that makes people go
yeah i'm going to pretend some [ __ ]
there's some guys at eddie's there's a
dude that pretended he was a yes purple
belt or something before
something like that right and he'd never
even gotten a blue or something like
that but you know the kid had aptitude
he was good he'd stuck with it but he
just wanted to be better than he was
which i always thought was a little
silly about like why are you chasing
about why why aren't you just here in
the art of it like who give a [ __ ] what
belt that is yeah i don't i don't care
at all
like i don't know it's a trip you know
to have that as the goal
as opposed to i want to be healthy i
want to be able to defend myself i want
to be able to move around i want to be
able to be with my pals every day
and to need a like that kind of
reinforcement like i need to have be in
the rankings
it kind of feels like uh you're [ __ ]
six yeah it feels like you're a little
kid you're trying to train at that uh a
stunt place yeah yeah down at 87. now
where is this uh down in inglewood and
hugh has they have like now they shoot
movies there and stuff right oh shoot
like previz's and um what is it for john
wick people yeah yeah yeah i know he
works yeah they do the uh they've done
all the really big action movies like
they do a lot a lot of the uh action
choreography for that shoot previous is
all the gun work and stuff for john wick
deadpool like all that type [ __ ] i heard
john wick was j and the second one too
was just amazing i heard it like
phenomenal i heard keanu was great like
i cuz i've seen some of the trailers you
know the difference lee is that you see
a guy like who's the guy that's 106
years old that was fighting wolves and
then his daughter got kidnapped liam
needs to take him yeah yeah and so you
see a simple
jump over the fence lee
liam
and it's like his feet his head his
waist the fence that and it's a hundred
different
little video montages to make it appear
as if a 75 year old man is actually
getting over a 12-foot fence it's not
happening but with keanu keanu moves
like that like he's a athlete and and
that's a lot of the reason why that
looks so good and they're i mean they're
the best choreographers too they're
fantastic man um and they got great
stunt men that are in all those like
just legends and and and beautiful
performers
top to bottom like those guys like
but that's that's the difference i think
is like you got a guy that can actually
do the bit you know you get a crin
semsworth or a or a keanu reeves or
something like that that can ha tom
cruise he does all his own [ __ ] it looks
great his [ __ ] looks great [ __ ]
what's that movie there with jamie foxx
oh the oh the driving one the tactics he
was very good dude he was like there's
times i watch those movies and i go dog
you know what say what you want to say
about tom cruise he's great he was i
just watched jack breacher on the flight
and was an academy award winner but i
love him entertaining i love him to
death so i i watch him i live with
sci-fi one where he like kept having the
same day over and over again
vanilla vanilla sky no no that was a
good movie it wasn't that one about the
one where they looked into his mind
about the cops
oh yeah uh
minority minority report yeah that was
great that's where we're almost living a
couple more weeks we'll be right there
i wouldn't doubt it
i got t have you ever thought
about like i do want to
expand in acting because you've done all
these roles with some such amazing
actors i can imagine like you you must
have learned so much from all the alley
all the movies now i don't know like
30 or 40 or something
i was i was going to say no i just want
to stay there i was going to give an
eddie bravo answer
like he loves to live troll people who
loves to live troll more and eddie
he's but yeah of course man of course
have you like how am i like um i take
classes and i i do all that and i work
out for a lot of things i'm in a thing
uh
me and danny trejo got a little piece
this weekend coming up and then
uh ross and thurber marshall's a dude
that did
a movie we
we were the millers
yeah yeah something like that right and
uh he'd met me on that before and then
he then that was a long time ago
and he so i got a little thing on his
next piece coming up here and so i think
it's just a lot of word of mouth it
takes time for that and also i came in
as a stunt man but i look like this and
so i'm not like a nondescript guy so
it's hard for guys to place me in places
so then i had to get good at acting
because then you're going to be in roles
and you're going to have facial
expressions and that and
and all the you know all that
that takes training and and so i kind of
took to that training like i
took to it with uh jiu jitsu or with
fights also you know and i think that
it's uh
maybe it's a thing that happens lee i
hope so you know i'd love to be like
somebody's asking well what are your
goals with it i'm like well i'd like to
be on a billboard i'd like to be on the
on the poster and have my name be one of
the four names that's there you know and
like i'd like to do all that like that's
where i really wanted to go and there's
nowhere that i have more fun is is a lot
like fighting when somebody yells action
i think and that's the other reason like
you know i want to spread into it so
much that i'm going to do it to however
i have to um which
also is like i want to go into stand-up
because that's a way you can kind of
force the hand and i think you get to
dictate the role
and you get to
whenever you want in in a way and
uh i think it's terrifying i think it's
as scary as
going into
being a fighter in the octagon or
anything else to get on stage i see guys
that do
stand up and i see guys that are open
micros and it fascinates me with the
kind of amount of courage that it takes
to really bury yourself and i think you
have to do it
with a huge risk you have to be super
real because if you're not super real
those are guys being around the comedy
store for all this time i look at guys
that
have done the same shtick for forever
and they've never really risked and
they're in the same place they were 10
15 years ago and then you see guys at
risk and you go [ __ ] man there and those
guys are all making a million dollars
just telling jokes you know and and
so i i don't know i really like those
aspects of it and i'm going to try to do
that but if you can help me i would like
that like i wish i could have if i could
help you i probably wouldn't be here but
it was uh like you're great in all the
movies that you're in but do you think
it would be difficult to say do you
think it'd be different do you think
it'd be harder if like you had just
maybe got not a starring role but like a
bigger role in a in a movie and you had
no experience i think it would be worse
yeah exactly that's what i'm saying yeah
no yeah that's you know it's like that
thing that they say uh you know god
gives you only what you can handle or
something like that like there's all
these sayings that are kind of like that
and i think it's i think it's like that
you think i think you know
eddie eddie taught me a lot about like
being on on a vibe with the universe in
a way and like
and
i think about that a lot and i meditate
on that kind of stuff and i you know i
try to elevate you know people somebody
said well what's your mission statement
you do all this different [ __ ] you got
you know you're getting money six
different ways or whatever and uh
and i said well i want to elevate myself
to be the best representation of tate
fletcher that i can be so i can be the
most useful to the people like my family
friends and community around me wherever
i am and especially now more than ever
with so much darkness in the external
world that i want the parts that i can
make better i want to be able to do that
and no so anyway that's kind of yeah i
don't know i think and i think also
doing stand-up
you know you watch it save people's
lives a lot of people and and
have you done it yet no [ __ ] i'm
sorry
nervous as [ __ ] about it really yeah
bobby lee says i'll have you up the
improv
for five minutes and get ready in a
month or whatever and i was like [ __ ] i
was hanging out with you guys for a long
time and you talk about jiu jitsu and it
used to drive me crazy and
those road trips with six people in the
van i wanted to shoot myself
and i liked you with all my heart and i
liked when duncan was there but red band
at that time was still under the
impression you know yeah the one that i
gave him blow and he ratted me out i
mean it was just it was just a world
that i had never been involved in yeah
but you guys kept talking about
jiu-jitsu
and i would go to eddie's and watch and
i'm gonna go i'm not doing that you know
i'm not doing that
and then i started watching it and i
became a fan of watching just regular
jiu-jitsu online marcelo garcia
um lucas laches like i would just watch
this [ __ ] not when i was cooked up when
i was smoking weed after that years
later and it took me two years to
actually walk into a jiu jitsu school it
took me
two years to break down how i was gonna
do this without nobody finding out if i
failed
okay that was the plan how i could do
jiu jitsu
without it getting back to eddie
or any of my friends that i even went in
there just in case i don't like it
you know what i'm saying weird how
that's like a thing what a [ __ ] shame
it was for me to go down there and i
probably went down there for three
months before i ever said anything to
anybody yeah and then i told daddy and
he would you know he was kind of weird
he goes what do you mean like i've been
going over that ski
and i talked to matt severan he goes the
first 90 days you want to be in a gee i
was completely lost you know
when i got
out of the prison in colorado
i could lie to you and tell you no i had
my mind was on how i was going to do the
next line you know what i'm saying sure
but three percent in that i was curious
about stand-up i was curious about going
back to school and finishing up my nine
credits and getting a degree
i had a job already but something that
was lurking inside of me so i got
released in february
of 89 okay of february of 89.
anybody got pen
here february of 89 and this is why i do
this
so just to show tape
i got out of jail february of 89.
in january
of 90 i thought about it
and i stretched it off like ah
and then
in january of 91
it was snowing so i had to stay home and
the movie
and the movie punchline came on
with tom hanks and sally fields yeah
yeah yeah
and that sent me into a tissy and i
actually called the comedy works
and they said come on down on the
tuesday
and that took another month or two what
did you say like i want to be a comic
book i like to know if you have an open
mic and they said yeah we have one every
tuesday night just call the tuesday
before we'll put you on the list for the
following
phone call to me and you get three
minutes okay
but from that phone call of january of
91
do you think i actually went down there
no no why
why would i but then one day i went to
get breakfast
and in april of 91
i saw an ad a whole section roseanne had
just busted out of
out of denver she had just broken up
denver comedy was booming nobody knew
where to go there was only four clubs in
the whole state
and they did an article like in the
rocky mountain news in the middle
like i was i walked into a diner
and did this
just to see the sports section and it
landed right in the middle and it was do
you want to be a stand-up comic
and it had how to become and it had a
course
for 31 at the university of colorado and
then started like a week later did you
go [ __ ] yeah for 33 dollars [ __ ] yeah i
went [ __ ] joey what'd they show you just
three weeks three weeks so and they say
right here's
pick an idea that pops in your head yeah
things around it that's funny to you but
my point being that after that the guy
said
because the final class you had to do
three minutes on stage right and as i
was walking i think i goes come in for a
second he goes you should try this
you should really maybe try you had
something up there and you're like 30
years old 35 31 32
yeah i'm an estimator for a roofing
company
really unhappy marriage that's where you
meet rick
uh about a month later that really
unhappy marriage really undecisive
snorting here and there hidden
by this time
it's better to want than to have my
mother had died and i always craved an
american family and i finally meet a
white chick and they have a family
and i like going up there and they sat
like white people and had dinners and
they prayed and it was shocking to me
you know this education he was a retired
colonel
lieutenant colonel from the air force
and
i don't know i just it was better than
one thing to have at that point and i
acted like an [ __ ] and we just
broke up one day but
finally
june
it's either 18th or 21st is when i went
on stage so it basically took me two and
a half hammering my [ __ ] blows me
away
so it took me two and either 18th 21st
time on 1991 oh yeah we could mother
mothership forever
so you know i want to explain that to
you
that fear is a [ __ ] yeah and
then if we go back to monday's podcast
it's not really fear it's called
resistance right it's called resistance
for years i was trying to write a book
i'd pop up to the book
lit lift but i also have twitter
facebook i'm sure you know and and then
i'll send you on twitter and somebody
sends you a picture that [ __ ] and you
need to jerk off first before you write
then you need to smoke then you need to
get some nicotine in a sandwich you know
what let me call tate now and see what
he's doing next month for lunch it's
resistance it's the same thing but with
your case
this is a realm that you've been around
for over 10 years
so i think it should just be comfortable
to you i think that you should go to a
bar open mic and i think you should open
up your calendar tomorrow
and maybe go to flappers and not say
nothing to nobody or
oh yeah definitely not everybody's like
well i want to be the one i go to no
that's going to happen i just want you
to do it do it for yourself
the best feeling i have in my life every
day is obvious when i kiss my daughter
and the feeling i have when i'm at home
when i walk out of jiu jitsu
for me
for you it might just be a walk in the
park it's just something you do
when i walk into jiu jitsu first of all
when i walk into jiu jitsu i know i'm
going to go in and tap out 18 [ __ ]
times i'm gonna have to stop to breathe
but i'm gonna sweat
i'm gonna mount
i'm gonna pass guards i'm gonna get my
neck choked i think that's the
resistance in a good way resistant death
and gravity and everything else like
that's what that kind of thing is you
know but yeah i pulled up to albertos
two times and pulled away
yeah you know i can't let nobody hear
the same thing so i get the fear i get
it
but i don't at this point because the
best i feel
is when i walk out of jiu jitsu because
i dare [ __ ] to come in front of
me i wish i could go from jiu jitsu to a
stand-up stage
it would be
not very good for people ah it would not
be that you were a [ __ ] monster i
couldn't imagine you bringing more
energy to that yeah no i walk out of
that jiu jitsu
with that last taste of testosterone
running through your body and you'll say
[ __ ] a little worse than what you're
saying it's a little bit more honest
the filters are off i know you can't
take like a seven o'clock class right
now but like
if you had like a mat in the back and a
shower would that be like the best like
roll for like an hour take a shower
change go on stage oh my god i would
they couldn't stop me on stage
i would be so fired up
like and for me
my excitement like
i never did any of this so like today i
rolled
we was too many people to roll so all we
did was break and pass guards right i
think i did six of them and i passed one
purple bounce guard
i got in that car like i had won a gold
medal yeah those victories are huge you
understand me so for me yeah if if every
time i wrestle with tate if he gets me
the spotty spider guard
but for some reason i wrestled this time
this eighth time i went with tate and he
didn't get me in the spider guard and he
got me the half guard i won in my mind
he didn't get me i kept my elbows close
to my body every time he tried to trick
me whatever i kept him close all that
stuff to me is a win
where most people wouldn't look at it as
a win you know what i'm saying yeah this
time the first couple of years i went
the first year just so i went i would
only roll one time five minutes at the
end of class i didn't have the energy
right but i would go today i went
128 tomorrow i'm going to go 131 yes and
i would let take it on top of me and i
would and i'd be down there breathing
[ __ ] thinking the world was going to
end anxiety it feels like that chest
coming in on you who the [ __ ] should i
want to come back not the next day yeah
i remember walking and then leaving like
a wheel in my car if i die take the car
there [ __ ] my wife because i thought
i was going to die in these classes yeah
that's how rough it was that's what i
still like about when i hashtag seek
death and like like
we talk on my podcast like keith and i
about about that about being in those
moments
where you
you're there to give your all you're
there to tempt death you're there to
push up against it
and and when you do there's a great
[ __ ] release that opens like your
chest opens in a different way and
cracks the light of god and spirit
through the whole universe that vibrates
and you're involved in the moment
like that is
more immortalizing really i think and i
don't think that if you go and you half
step and don't commit to those it's like
watching you on stage last night
if you would have been like
on a [ __ ] tear going these [ __ ]
chinese people and go and go these
[ __ ] chinese peop like and let it
drop that's you just lost everybody
you but and that and that's that thing
that being fully committed man that i
didn't have that peace in life for a
long time but man is that [ __ ] a huge
investment you make in yourself
and you know for years
joe diaz would have gone in there last
night looked around the room
saw one person with white hair and go
i can't do is that right oh yeah little
things would throw you off your [ __ ]
plan
like when i hear about fight plans in
the mma
right we went over this 80 [ __ ] times
stay away from his [ __ ] left you went
into his [ __ ] left you know the same
thing happens on stage sometimes you you
fall into ruts where you don't like and
i would get discouraged by psychological
things
there's six whole women in the front
seat there goes my [ __ ] like some ocd
[ __ ] yeah like i can't do that material
i can't do that material now i don't
give a [ __ ] yeah if you come into a
comedy club you gotta go i'm willing to
accept whatever whatever and i'm gonna
stick to this joke if that joke
has to say something off color
and it's
up
uh towards a particular race and there's
six of those [ __ ] in the front
row you're gonna go up there because
it's not what you say it's how you say
sure
these are the things you learn
the thing about stand up the first three
or four times
and i've had this conversation a
thousand times with people different
people wanting to get on stages i want
you just to do it and get an overwatch
and it sounds so
huge but it's so mighty do you think you
can write anything out or prepare
anything or just go walk on stage and
burn onto the lights i'd rather you go
up there and burn the lights i'd rather
you go up there and tell your name like
you did in school yeah what would you
bring us to the uh tate today i brought
you a truck it's a hot wheels my uncle
worked hard to get it for me i used to
have a purple one but my dog squat ate
it now i have this one
thank you thank you and you you got it
over with
now you know what feelings you're gonna
expect now you know what type of
emotions you're gonna go through now
you're gonna know you know what joey
told me not to look at their faces don't
look at their [ __ ] faces i've been
doing it 25 years you see me looking at
people [ __ ] faces i heard the first
ten minutes was it mitch hedberg that
turned around and faced the curtain
exactly yeah man
like that's [ __ ] phenomenal just
because he wasn't feeling and he was
experienced he just wasn't feeling it
that day he's like i can't do this i'm
just gonna tell my jokes to the to the
blank wall
that's crazy but it's a craziness man
it's an interesting thing to be around
too because it's all these
such unique beautiful representations of
humanity all parts in between and
it's amazing what what comes down to the
story you know when you see all the that
is like a unit little universe
i gotta tell you something you know
joe rogan goes off some some warm some
[ __ ] up tangents and
one thing he's always said he says i
always felt there was a certain light
that
shone on that to attract all those
people to that place
it's something weird about that place
that has
so many different people all the people
have walked in that stage you know from
prior to
tom papa kennison jennison to just
but it's not that like it's just hanging
out there
yeah it's like going it's like being a
musician and going to the rock not the
roxy the one down the corner from the
store the whiskey the wood not the
whiskey the one there's the one let me
use the hang out uh oh
well let me use the hang out and people
go in there and you go in there there's
heavy metal guys yeah
you know if you're going to play music
that's where your ultimate place is to
go is to go there and see what it's also
like the rainbow the rainbow it's like a
university
like because you go in there and you get
you see duncan answering the phones and
then you see him graduate onto you know
doing what he's doing now or whatever
and like you've i've seen that with a
bunch of different doc
[ __ ] doc that was parking like and
he's blown up now he's doing great
and that's all he's doing telling jokes
because he quit yeah because he quickly
took away the safety net yep stand up is
a very weird animal
but it's no different than any other art
you're ever gonna do it's just doing it
getting it over analyzing it which
you'll do perfectly after the first time
and then you'll be more prepared the
second time then you'll be more prepared
the third time and the good thing about
you is stand-up is gonna be for you how
jiu-jitsu is for me
you know right now you're not really
planning on going on the road you have a
lot of [ __ ] happens like know on tour
for two months and right an hour so
right now you're gonna focus on two ten
minute sets as as as
you know and again
time nobody knows time to you're on
stage right oh yeah three minutes is a
[ __ ] eternity that's what i say to
dudes about work about training like we
do we do training sessions i'm like
listen if you don't understand how long
five seconds can be of suffering like
there's five seconds left on the clock
and you've got to keep moving and coach
is yelling at you and there's a dummy
underneath your elbow and name or
whatever like then you haven't worked
hard
like when you know that like what seems
like a short amount of time is [ __ ]
eternity in there and you're burning
through it and it hurts every moment
like all the seconds are broken into 100
parts
[ __ ] that's different man what about
when you got a 10 minute set that you
got to do and you go blank and you're
under the light you're getting money for
rent oh that was too much and at the 2
minute mark you're dying
you're dying you can't get them back
your experience can never get them back
at this point because that's all
experience is is losing them and getting
them back
losing and getting them back you know
what i've seen people go up there and
say horrible things
and then switch it up
and you know this shows i do but i'm a
magician
because i go to a like last weekend i
went to uh
minnesota minnesota house of comedy
great club but you know what man
right now at this point i just shot a
special
and the last two months has been deadly
on the writing not good i'm trying to
write a book
so the writing i'm doing for comedy is
right
like it's just not getting together but
i got a couple bright spots
you know i'm saying like there's a
couple little things that once i put
four it's like a constellation
i'm building a constellation now i need
to get eight stars right now i got one
if i could get two more that's 20
minutes
now the last 20 will come like nothing
but the first 20 to tighten them up
and to go from my daughter to the
immigration bill to this to that that's
the group that i'm working on right now
i love that immigration piece i know
it's a little [ __ ] hair away
but i'm going through a slump so what do
you do when there's a slump you stop
playing okay no you just because you got
submitted 10 days in a row you don't
even gonna come back now no this is when
you come back
because by the 18th day that's when it's
all going to come to you
so the last well and i think that's what
commitment is that's what coming up
because because you don't give a [ __ ]
like at the thing
like when you when i feel like i
plateaued and i'm like well i just i
just keep coming
because there's nothing else
this is the thing that i do like and
when that becomes the thing that you do
like it doesn't matter how you know i
was tripping out about baseball players
the other day a friend of mine is like
you know if you want to be in the hall
of fame
you need to hit 30 of the balls that's
failure everywhere in life
if you make a 30 on a test you [ __ ]
you're you wrote your name you're
[ __ ] the baseball hall of fame but
like if you hit three out of ten balls
or four out of ten balls no one hits
four out of ten no one has ever had four
like ted williams was the last guy to
hit 400. so imagine that bro you get no
that's amazingly you you get up on the
plate so right yeah and imagine you need
one joke to go momentum into the next
joke
imagine if you're gonna suck dicks every
[ __ ] time or
seven or eight out of ten times but you
get up with the same kind of power and
panache that can hit a home run every
time that's a mental discipline i mean
i'm sure there's some of those baseball
players that just throw it away but the
guys that are good that pay attention
that try on every shot
to me that's phenomenal man it hasn't
been done since uh ted williams did it
i i don't even know what year it was
let's see crazy yeah that's and so
that's a trip to me like that to
to mark my reinforcement by going like
when you're saying about the stars and
you're like
and then the last 20 will come easy to
not dread it because i think there's
something about the way i feel about the
thing that i do
going into it it's like i can't dread it
i've got like or i can and it gets done
but it's way more arduous than it needs
to be if i'm just excited and
you know let me break it down to jiu
jitsu terms what if
what if
your father was a black belt in jiu
jitsu
and every day from the age of five
to the age of 12
he [ __ ] around with you with a comoro
you could bang a comoro with two fingers
all you need to do is grab the guy's
wrist and exactly your arm knows how to
do it yep but guess what
you got to pass my guard to get my
kimura right you have no experience in
passing my guard that's what i got to do
now
right now i have the bits in the
beginning
now i have to figure out the pass
and how they all mix together so you're
going to teach me the
the one step behind to break the pass
and then i'm gonna try to get the two
underhooks and put pressure on them and
grab this
thing and pull myself in you're gonna
teach me all the pads right now i got
the
the things i just don't have the pads
right that's going to take another month
or so it's cool
it's cool that you've done it enough
that you know the last time it takes but
over a month let me tell you something
january and december and my mind were
brutal is that right
i didn't want to get on stage now were
you going up just as regularly as always
yeah always if i'm out of town if i go
out of town i do five sets out of town
and one on tuesday
there's a comedy giant right up the road
here right yeah flappers no there's a
haha right down the corner and there's
another one with the big marquee outside
yeah flat brush
is that what it is yeah there's two the
one is closed down oh you drove past two
of them maybe yeah but one of them is
closed down on like the show shake it
down shaky town
the haha yeah shaky because on the other
side yeah yeah so if we get out of here
early we go then we'll put you up
tonight
10 30.
we'll get you out of here
because that's the only way to do it
bust your nut i can't have no no i'm not
busting you know no but to go out there
and just break
i'd rather drop it on you at seven yeah
drop it on you at eight in the morning i
don't want you in that house all day
yeah how am i gonna get out of this i
can't call joey oh i know joey 15 years
how am i going to get i might get a flat
tire on the way yeah yeah i might even
stage an accident i mean that's how bad
it [ __ ] again
but that's why i would drop it on you
like seven like what are you doing yeah
no pick me up let's go to dinner on the
way after dinner let's stop at the
sportsman's lodge there's an open mic
and i just throw you know it's like when
your father takes you swimming
don't you know how to swim let me hold
on boom they throw you in you flap
around it takes ya that's it now you
leave there going
joey i can't believe i got thanks
you're a [ __ ] scumbag you'll probably
even punch me and be mad but i still
shake everything he did it he did it he
did it he did it really yeah i did like
three or four times i think yeah and for
my special they brought they brought
them up they made them go up yeah i
didn't i didn't plan that on this i
didn't think you're gonna problem cd but
you can't think about it right
you know i was telling lee when i was a
sports salesman that i would always kick
on saturdays in the sports
selling business i was always number one
on the board what do you think
because i did an eight ball on friday
night i went to work
unconscious yeah so i went back to
basics
you know that's the best coaches like
you look at how greg jackson coaches
guys you see a lot of guys they're like
i want to see that four punch
combination or whatever and they it's
too much greg's just there okay i need
you to breathe i need you to breathe
okay let's try to count 12 jabs out in
the next round and then it'll be just
that it'll be just simple nothing but
it's like because the truth is if i'm
trying to work this four punch cut
whatever the thing is i'm too late
anyway i gotta rely just on my [ __ ]
charisma of all of the years of training
that i've built into my movement that
i'm just going to move in a scrap the
way it is because it's a scrap it's not
technique driven so much as it is the
momentum driven of what you've written
into your body into your musculature on
how to move right and that's i think the
magic place to get for fighters is like
who are you at your best day in the gym
has that guy ever seen the lights of
competition most guys would say no
you know and i and i think i think it's
the same thing with like with comedy
with i mean with so many art forms it's
like we need that pressure to be able to
polish that [ __ ] diamond absolutely
absolutely all right it's never done art
is hard as hard as art
i'm going to tell you something you
don't think i'm crazy since i started
jiu jitsu my stand up has gotten better
oh 100 i know for a fact i know for a
fact i feel the difference at all i feel
the breathing i feel how everything has
affected how i've thought and combined
them together me writing is me being on
my back nobody likes to do that
nobody wants to be on this black body
wants to write you know uh just so many
different things like you know we were
talking about one day when you are a
very intelligent guy you might come to
me when they go joey did you watch my
son last night i go yeah
that [ __ ] joke he's bombing i go
that joke's a funny joke
the problem is
you're not experienced enough to say
something about the way you're saying
that joe just ain't right selling it's
there it's a joke
put that joke away and try it again in
three years when you have confidence
from a different angle
you know and things like that always
have you ever asked for help with like
when you like or or maybe not now
anymore but like when you were young
and like starting out in it did you ever
go to like [ __ ] another comic and go
hey look at this what do you think of
this how do we form this better and get
help with that or would that be like uh
i don't want to
i don't want to have anybody else's
fingerprints on my thing no i think that
i don't
i won't i don't ever want to call let's
say tate becomes a great joke writer i
don't ever want to call paint and go hey
write me 30 minutes i'll pay you 3 000
i would never do it i'm the type of guy
i don't want you writing for me at all
but what if i wrote my i'm writing my
own and i'm going how do i make this
better joey
do you have an opinion on that or do you
go i don't want to put my fingerprints
on your [ __ ] tate okay so no no no we're
gonna discuss this right now so let's
pretend
me and you meet three times a week
monday wednesday and friday
yeah
and
you're like my trainer for jokes yeah so
me and you are gonna write together okay
okay
listen man
two heads are better than one three
heads are better
four heads about it
all those years when chris rock had
three of those specials that were
tremendous specials
okay
what people don't know is
let's say hbo would give him a 250 000
advance
he would take 50 and give it to nick
depaolo a tremendous joke writer he
would take another 50 and give it to
richard jenny as good as the business
gets and he would take another 50 and
give that to louis ck
okay
because he's got the lego he knows okay
he knows okay so
did these guys write a material for him
not at all
if you'd watch him on monday nights if
you were at the store
he'd meet up with nick at the improv
about 8 50. do a 10-minute set
then i'm going to drive to the laugh
factory him and nick would talk about
more [ __ ] and he'd do another spot
and then they closed out the store
and if they were lucky enough they'd go
back to the [ __ ] laugh factory and
write that bit again
and he would do the same on tuesday
night with
whatever his name is and then on
wednesday night he would team up with
louis ck
so by the end of that special yeah it's
a 60-minute special but i guarantee
you each of those wrote 15 minutes
that's why those specials are so good
bigger and blacker
the one before that where what do you
say you know
there's just something about being black
about being rich and wealthy you know
whatever there's a big thing between
being black and there's a big
opportunity to being a [ __ ] all those
brilliant
specials were when he was running with
rich jenny
and that's what a smart comic does these
guys started together they know each
other like freaking me you and lee were
white belts 15 years ago i know lee
likes the north south i know you like a
[ __ ] come over so now we don't
train no more right but i'm training
with cabrini now lee's gone on to train
with john jock guess what when you're
gonna fight next time and that guy's a
jiu jitsu specialist yeah me and lee are
gonna come down you're just gonna put us
up and feed us right and we're gonna
work you
you follow it's the same [ __ ] day
you're gonna come we're gonna go to
remember that come on these guys that
are joke writers don't really write
you know knock knock who's there they
don't write the joke
they're just
helping him see the thing from a
different angle and bring out more funny
yeah and if you would watch
chris rock's specials
that's sarcasm he has great sarcasm but
take combining with nick apollos
you're [ __ ] special is brilliant
so if i if each of these guys never feel
sorry sorry because they're like dude i
gave him my best joke no because it's
not really theirs it's like a thing
that's grown yeah i got it yeah
i never knew that i always had it
backwards i always figured like when
these guys they get joke raiders i
didn't know that that's that's a cool
style there's a lot i like this style
better yes
hbo comes to me tomorrow and goes we're
going to give you half a million dollars
on advance pay you know we'll give you a
quarter of a million up front and a half
i'm going to get three of the best fifth
guys i know until today
not necessarily i'm to get joe rogan or
chris rock sure i might get a feature
act that nobody's seen before you see
that fajim kid
is he [ __ ] up last night he's so good
dog his specials coming out of the sea
so i'm gonna have a mom i'm gonna try to
get him on next week he's [ __ ] dude i
i was like i'm just like inspiring to
watch like no he's a bad [ __ ]
he's dangerous he's like he was like a
former engineer like he's really smart
it comes across man it comes across and
that dude i like him like i saw him go
in and out of characters and the problem
with [ __ ] dudes that are like comic
character guys is that they live that
character then they become if it's a
douchey guy they're douchey guys if it's
like a sparta like hey whiz bang sports
fan and then then they're that guy and
but i saw you see a guy like that go in
and out of characters and he's still so
solid on his feet of who he uh he's
[ __ ] phenomenal he's phenomenal
[Music]
this special that i just shot for ceso
yeah i had a cat willie barceta help me
all right willie barcena's done 19
tonight shows
so he knows the short set i didn't want
the special to be filthy
you know what i'm saying i wanted to be
more me so i would write the material
perform and send them the performances
and he would write three or four
different things and that was it he told
me put this here
don't use that word because we're here
to win a [ __ ] fight not to lose that
i'm saying right so there was a lot of
things that we went back and forth no
arguments no nothing i trusted him 150
percent
he didn't write my special at all
he helped me i would leave with tape to
sets with me i would tape him on my
phone and the next morning i'd email him
to willy and willie would send me notes
so by the time i got back from austin on
sunday willie would have all his sets
and tuesday when we'd meet he'd have two
pages of notes that's dope and i would
go home the rest of the week and
practice that [ __ ] at flappers or at the
haha and just that's an interesting
thing too there's no help there's no
doing it there's no practicing that [ __ ]
at home you're oh you have to put your
ass on the line
and you might go and look silly you got
to risk everything you got to go and
risk it
me shooting a special i looked at it as
me training for a fight against anderson
so
that was it it's the same thing you
gotta do the same [ __ ] every day you
gotta sleep eat
i gotta think about this i gotta get up
and my back hurt right i've never sat
that much in my life now i do exercises
while i'm sitting down
if i'm sitting that long but i was
trying to write in like two hour chunks
smoke dope run errands come back go to a
coffee shop now change locations two
hours go home and that night after
everybody went to bed i'd go to
starbucks till midnight
over here excuse me i'm magnolia so i
always had different things to
to you know i don't like yeah yeah you
know
i have a conversation with lee i love
jujitsu but there's only one thing i
like about jiu jitsu a day like today
who the [ __ ] wants to roll
inside on the day like today you know
what i'm saying you know a day like
today i would usually blow up jiu jitsu
get kettlebells go to noho park swing
five sets couple cleans a couple squats
and just walk around the track
stretch out get some sun that sweat is a
natural yes whatever i love right now
outside in the sun
like i love it i love it there's
something about you know if you read uh
uh steven spielsberg's book on writing
it's called on writing very interesting
book he talks about a way that
he used to have his room and how
he breaks it down from [ __ ]
really oh
stephen king and i'm writing breaks it
down stephen king not steven spielberg
no stephen king i'm sure yeah so order
it right now on amazon you're gonna love
it
he has great [ __ ] because he's like uh
he's a real [ __ ] dude that dude did
coke and everyone really yeah bro i just
heard this [ __ ]
like he was on sons of anarchy you know
there's a trip because i was yeah he was
on sunset as a kid i was i i was
figuring if you're successful you're on
the street that's what they sell you
that's if you you're on the straight and
narrow if you're success and like he's a
successful writer so you know in the
meantime how the [ __ ] do you think you
all our heroes kill themselves and [ __ ]
you know
yeah right kills people yeah you know i
think he had terry the dog the [ __ ]
hey carrie was a piece of paper it was a
couple pages that he had wrote
about he was a janitor at the time in
new hampshire or wherever the [ __ ] he
was living
and he was working as a janitor in a
high school or grammar school i don't
know you'll correct me after you read
this
and he saw the period box
in the girls bathroom
so he wrote a couple lines about that
and then he wrote a couple lines about
people who have sumo u
super human natural brain abilities
right people that can move stuff
so he took whatever he had he wrote like
30 pages on it he threw in the garbage
and that night when he got home from
work his wife took it out of the garbage
and said i read this this is really good
that's carrie crazy how [ __ ] crazy
that's the wild thing too is like how
we're never good enough for our own [ __ ]
yeah yeah
he's gonna break down so much [ __ ] for
you when it it's just an interesting
book it's cool whether you want to be a
writer or not right i mean this is just
a book and this guy's been infected and
i think he talks about his addictions
and like he was snorting blow it to
write you know yet last night i was
watching something before i went to the
stall about ernest hemingway sat at the
same [ __ ] place every day and wrote
and got a ham and hammered be hung out
there for 10 [ __ ] years you know uh
the guy that fear unloading in las vegas
yeah there's no [ __ ] guy buckowski
burkowski with this fight you know they
were all
into the dope uh the spanish guy
the one that uh the guy that created
miami vice but everybody yeah yeah yeah
yeah they each got to have something
this is what takes that imagination i
remember one time
tate and i were at
tate's gonna go joe diaz get the [ __ ]
out of here
tate and i were in austin texas
at the uh what's the name of the
restaurant we go to the across from the
hotel pavados papados and me and eddie
and all those guys but me and tate would
get into a conversation about how alice
and chains wrote their music
on heroin look at him he's going oh my
god
and i'm gonna take looking at me going
that's interesting like tate was heavy
into the you know you were very sober
then you were very proud and you were
like that's interesting i can't imagine
joey you went like
[Music]
what's that song they do
wood yeah isn't it yeah man in the box
or or
uh
here comes the uh
rooster
the one we were talking about was
if you listen to
that whole [ __ ] album
it's laced
with heroin
down in a hole
if you've ever been in a hole yeah you
know exactly you know who they wrote
like under a different beat is [ __ ]
lou reed lou reed used to write [ __ ]
poetry man street poetry about [ __ ]
dope and hookers and [ __ ] [ __ ]
everything man he was the [ __ ] man
that's these on on on
down in the hole i have it on my ipod
and it's like the second song i listen
to when i have 2 000 milligrams of thc
in me
and i put my seat belt on
that's the second tone i have like an
order on the plane
and i listened to down the hole like two
or three times in the first
section of lyrics
you know holding red flowers in the tomb
and all that [ __ ] down in the hole and i
don't know if i could be straight or
what
i could feel this pain yeah i could feel
what the [ __ ] they were writing i mean
when he sang that he had no teeth on mtv
yeah and no [ __ ] teeth
the heroine how bad does it get when
your teeth are [ __ ] gone how good is
it how good is it oh yeah that's the
other side i mean it's so good i'll get
him started he's gonna start bringing
heroin in again
man it's not again but so good it's like
that and people don't they don't get it
it's like that's how good it is
like i can be pulling scabs i watch last
time i saw a dude shoot up i was in
vancouver and i was uh looking out the
window this alley
and this dude's trying to hit his neck
and the only time anybody tries to hit
their neck is because all their other
veins are gone nothing's available right
and and you know
and so he and he can't get and i'm like
and i'm watching for [ __ ] 10 minutes
15 and i'm uncomfortable as [ __ ] i'm
like i hope come on get this time get it
like i'm
i'm like him i'm like i've become him
and and [ __ ] he finally hits it and
that relief comes and and it is it's a
it's like a wind tunnel of dirt and
scabies just blowing through this
[ __ ] alley there's 30 junkies all in
there strewn about the place and [ __ ]
he's there and he [ __ ] gets it it's
just like
and you just know he's home
and [ __ ] man did we shoot anything yeah
did you shoot coke yeah coke and heroin
and morphine what'd you think of the
coke shooting i don't like it so much i
i did it a few times with a buddy of
mine because
like that he he liked it because as soon
as it hit his veins he'd throw up and
he's like then i could know how good the
coke was if i was gonna buy weight and
like it was just like it it was like he
would get a taste like that and that was
his that was his thing you know um
i can't imagine shooting up on a daily
basis on a multiple times a day basis
it's one of the things like when i when
i first got clean and i go uh
you know a couple months in i didn't
have nothing out like there's nothing to
look forward to if not for years for me
there's nothing for years but
one of the things was that i didn't have
to get high any anymore and that and
like and there's a different thing like
when you say i can't imagine doing it on
a daily basis like like uh the thing is
is like you can't imagine not because
like your hope that's all that's all the
life is that's the word that's the only
place you get freedom i got one friend
who shoots uh speed
now yeah and he um
and uh he was clean for a while any
whatever whatever but he hits it man
sometimes he says he'll he'll [ __ ]
put powder in the barrel and he'll draw
blood to mix the blood yeah yeah so
there's no dilution right and he hammers
it and he says and when i i said i said
are you getting any relief anymore at
all are you getting is there any freedom
in there because that's what we're
hunting man and uh
and he goes he says you know i blast it
and [ __ ] my my knees will [ __ ]
shake and give out and right before i
drop to the ground i feel [ __ ] free
i'm so free and and that's always
getting is that millisecond right there
anymore right but he's still you know
you can't get away from it
it's [ __ ] crazy man it's like it's a
wild thing you know that's why i think
we're built to have fun we're built to
feel good man i got to push all the ways
to feel good and to have fun that i can
because like there's i mean however you
do it you do it like whatever it is but
like some are more sustainable than
others you know okay i mean i'm not
gonna i can't sit here
from the age of 16
to when i got locked up at 27.
if there was no coke i wouldn't leave
the house oh
like if you called me and said joey i
got three chicks here we're gonna rock
and roll did you get anything no i
couldn't get anything what about your
friend nah
i'm not gonna go down there yeah to
stand in the bar and drink three beers
that's not gonna happen i mean the house
sad is that tasty pathetic it's [ __ ]
pathetic but but like dudes would ask me
they'd go what would you do coke what
would you do like
or like what what are you gonna do like
let's let's go go go go the cl i'm not a
club guy i'm [ __ ] not that like it's
like that's not something i'm like oh it
really makes me miss drinking or
something like to see a bunch of
[ __ ] at a club like it's not my
thing but like
that i'm like i'm doing coke what do you
mean like
they're like well what are you gonna do
tonight i'm like
it's called doing cocaine i'm gonna look
out the window some i'm gonna have the
[ __ ] tv on with the volume turned way
down and i'm gonna do cocaine until
there's no cocaine left and i'm gonna
stay up for as long as that takes like
and and i'm gonna [ __ ] it's gonna be
like that and like and then i remember i
got locked up once on a friday and so
i'm there until monday probably to see
the judge right and a dude hits me up he
comes in he goes hey he says hey you
want to do some blow i go
oh how much boy you got
he goes i got a quarter gram i go no
and i didn't have a problem saying no
because i could not imagine the feeling
of what that craving is like when i get
that in me that i'm gonna [ __ ] sit
there for 72 hours wanting more [ __ ] you
i'll chew through your neck you [ __ ]
sucker when i got sentenced
that morning i got sentenced you know i
say my goodbyes
i got a suit on i walk into the [ __ ]
cell there's a camera i'm by myself
there's a [ __ ] toilet another thing i
had been snorting for three days
straight
and three because they called on friday
and said
community corrections didn't take them
you gotta go convince this [ __ ] judge
or he's going to jail
they told me this friday at five so that
changed all the whole i thought i was
going to court and i was gonna walk out
there that's how [ __ ] delusional i
was that's what planet i [ __ ] was at
yeah kidnapping a machine gun yeah sure
you're gonna beat it
right right but the cocaine was like i'm
gonna go in there monday i'll talk to
the judge i swear to god today
like i have no reason to let you take
like i was like i was going there monday
and i put some [ __ ] i thought the
judge helped i'll give him a story
i couldn't even talk and that judge said
do you have anything to say oh i
couldn't even talk you know me though i
could talk for hours i was like
i couldn't talk from being nervous and
he sentenced me i went in the back and i
have to haul that tape
i go in the back and it was one of those
suits where you put the coke in and you
hide it and you forget
and for some reason i'm sitting in the
prison cell at 20 minutes now i'm going
through my clothes like just wow look at
this shirt i take the jacket off
and for some reason i took the napkin
out of the hole
and there it is front and center a rock
of coke
that i had been saving since god knows
when and i just crunched it up in front
of the camera with my fingers in the
suit pocket
i went in my wall i took a dollar bill
out
i put the whole dollar bill on that
[ __ ] thing and i went back to the
faucet and turned it on
snorted the whole [ __ ] gram in there
one shot because by that time that's
what i was doing right when i was 27
yeah i could do a whole [ __ ] bag at
one shot yeah i flushed it down the
toilet with the dollar bill
i waited for them to come but they
didn't seem to be in the cash
clean first and brother let me tell you
something
i think 10 minutes in the coke was
tremendous
but between the uh the relief
of knowing i was going to jail and
everything else right i [ __ ] passed
out
passed out like passed out like woke up
like at seven o'clock when i did that
coke it was
one in the afternoon and it was a gram
which for an hour you're sitting there
[ __ ] jawn
it didn't even hit me that way like
because
the release the relief of knowing that i
was going to it was for a year i was
living in this yeah when the other
hammer's going to know everybody i'm
talking to is like good luck we'll see
what happens yeah we'll leave in god's
hands
as much as you think you're going to
beat something you know
i i i was convinced because of my
cocaine addiction that i was going to
talk him into a work release job and i
was going to snort culture
kidnapping machine gun and kidnap this
cocaine is so good
at [ __ ] people up that your whole
life can be spiraling down the [ __ ]
with turds right behind it and you think
you're killing it killing it i thought i
was i thought i was going [ __ ] like
crazy no no no i thought i was going to
go on this move to judge over yeah like
this is the beauty of this at 30
i know i started coming i went to prison
in 87 which made me 24 years old at 24
years old i thought i was going to
actually go in there and smooth the
judge over like judge let me talk to you
but i got sentenced august 15th of 88
so that means i was 25 years old and i
went to prison and i'm like yeah i'm
gonna go talk to him that's how [ __ ]
i was at 20 [ __ ] five let me go talk
to this guy do you remember what your
lawyer was saying
my lawyer was telling me to keep my
[ __ ] mouth shut
you know my lawyer was phenomenal i mean
he
did an amazing [ __ ] job i recently
called him and said really found him and
i said listen i didn't want your work to
be in vain
like i finally got my life together i'm
a comedian i'm married i have a child
i'm 50
and he was like
you can't be telling me this [ __ ]
he goes my no so that was the
conversation we had the first day then
the second day he called me
and he goes i went home and told my son
my son knows everything about you yeah
you were in the longest yard though
he goes jesus christ he goes he's
studying to be in film so i said when he
becomes a big director tell him to call
his uncle joey you know yeah don't call
me now call me but yeah what took you to
seattle then
abroad yeah abroad and
yeah
i to stop with that goddamn camp did
they have a did they have a better uh
did they have a better comedy scene
there or anything like that absolutely
big city it's like a real it's like l.a
like that city's a huge [ __ ] west
coast city denver at the time was
mckelvey's wits end
now is the place that i've been to in
denver is that was that open back then
denver comedy works the place that it
got all brick and [ __ ] it's [ __ ] real
nice yeah big old yeah it's been there
since 81. i love that building i just
got a sweatshirt from them like they ran
over i just found it they gave it to me
when i was there in august but i just
found it i must have put it in a closet
and it was like their 50th anniversary
you know denver only had the comedy
works and those other two clubs but
before those two clubs open
they would have to go to a boulder in
boulder it was a jazz club called the
blue note
and that's where like roseanne did
comedy i mean everybody was doing
tomorrow yeah
is that because the college was more
like they had better venues for like no
no that's all they had available for
comedy it was a jazz club
you know if you look into the history of
comedy over the years it was done with
burlesque and then it was done very
out on guard like in the uh
60s and then like in the 70s is when i
think the first comedy club popped up
like i've heard different stories
pittsburgh
the funny bone in pittsburgh which is
not that normal
i would guess that it's like
kind of like
th the first guy is the guy that's
in between bringing up acts and he's
telling little jokes he's like how am i
going to fill the space in between the
baton twirler and the [ __ ] lion tamer
he's like i'll tell some and like it
started as like that kind of job i bet
and then somebody goes i wonder if
somebody would just like to see that all
the time and then there's a headline
comic made like you know what i mean
it's like because they're guys that have
stage presence that have charisma that
can sway a crowd pump a crowd up
ultimate hype man
keep them laughing you know
i wonder where they were born from those
first comics
they're doing a show right now on cnn
called the history of comedy
i watched 15 minutes of what i had i was
busy that night i don't know what night
it comes on
but i think
like vaudeville but i know they have
like [ __ ] cavemen drawings
or some guy up there hit the drum with
his dick or something that's gotta be
you know
there had to be humor i mean they talked
about with jokers and
one of those people called jesters yeah
whatever
somewhere along the line i guarantee
we're going to see bricks of [ __ ]
stand-up clubs in africa
some guy and if you were really bad they
just threw a spear at you yeah you know
what i'm saying that just chuck the
[ __ ] spear right through your [ __ ]
heart if you're gonna be entertainment
in one kind or another let me give some
shout outs here real quick yeah to my
[ __ ] in the game
samari army swarmy army whatever the
[ __ ] it is our gun machado
gabor james harrison
x
z podcast
the whole month he currently is harming
real joe williams and my man matthew
stone
i love you [ __ ]
anyway where were we sorry i love that
yeah you gotta let him know you know you
see him on twitter or facebook man i
love interacting dude i like i try to
answer all the goddamn snapchats and
i'll tell you though i [ __ ] up i don't
know if i [ __ ] up or not lee can be
the judge but i i was down in mexico you
know scotty that runs on the mat yes yes
he's friends with john salami and stuff
yeah yeah and so
he's got a hospital down there like a
cancer remediation and drug therapy kind
of fuzzy yeah they do curse and juicing
and i did hyperbaric chambers i did they
do coffee enemas all day long to kind of
to release uh
this antioxidant that lives in your
liver basically and and uh and cleans
you out and
they do
they do everything they did ozone they
take my blood out they put it through an
ozone machine and then they put it
through uv light put it back in kills
all the viruses in your body like they
do all types of [ __ ] and uh so i'm down
there and i'm doing animals and these
guys you're not on snapchat you can't
even i gotta remind you about tech yeah
you know geno at speedweed he got he's
like uh i got a picture that joey it's
on joey's phone but he's not good at
texting i go you're [ __ ] right he's
not and
he says see if you can get so we got to
remember remind us you're not going to
remember look at you i don't remember no
it's uh i'm okay but what happened with
the uh anyway so i go down there and i
get all these guys they can add you on
your story so you're just [ __ ] it's
an onslaught of
pictures of dogs and their lunch and
then this and then that on snapchat i'm
like hey how about don't do that because
i like to interact with people and i
don't need to be out of your timeline
anyway long and short of it i [ __ ]
got an enema
thing and i got coffee in it and then i
take a picture of that send it to like
30 guys that all have [ __ ] savaged me
with their boring [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then a picture of the hose and then
a picture of my [ __ ] was the finisher
for him and i i [ __ ] send that out to
all these guys and they're like holy and
then the finisher finisher was what was
in the toilet after the animal comes out
i don't know i just i and i'm like
you're welcome how about keep me off
your [ __ ] timelines since then it's
been real nice in my neighborhood now
wait a second so
i don't do snapchat i know i get
confused as it is
i'm good with twitter i'm good with
paris you're good at myspace yeah i used
to be good on myspace but i'm not good
on this other [ __ ] snapchat you guys i'm
impressed with how much you do on
periscope
like you're a savage on there well i do
two
before the podcast and i try to do one
on monday and fridays especially from a
different city that's cool want to smoke
a joint give him a look
do do you live stream
this
yes you do live stream it yeah yeah it's
going on right now on youtube god damn
i'm glad i beat my snots all right oh
stop
[ __ ] please don't talk about that
again i'm just teasing him oh he doesn't
he's not that's it don't talk about it
right you know what i'm gonna talk about
you i'm gonna tell the story from today
sure no i can't tell you the story about
the snot today anyway too savage no i
said shoot so give yourself uh look at
the calendar tonight when you go home
yeah look at the rooms and look at the
you know they got all the oh
i'll tell you where you're gonna go with
tommy easter goes
marty's marty's nobody's gonna see you
there all right nobody's gonna know who
you are cool
you're gonna know yourself where does it
pay three bucks it's right in hollywood
on sunset and uh
i gotta write it in it's right acro
right down the block from the [ __ ]
israeli restaurant
on sunset my favorite aroma aroma
i like aroma yeah it's right down the
block from how's the roll of israeli
it's it's a it's actually a coffee shop
in israel
like it's really yeah they got one on
studio city too right yeah no that's
that they're not related oh they're not
no the aroma in hollywood that's where
they have the salmon
[ __ ] delicious they got a they got a
couple good [ __ ] dishes in there jack
marty's on sunset yeah yeah
is that what it's called did you get the
picture i said every night
yeah seven nights a week okay
i think it's like five bucks to get five
bucks and you go and you get on stage
ten times in one night if you want
because they just can't i did i got it
they just keep rotating you
so it's [ __ ] tremendous
i'm really proud of you
this will change your life i'm excited
to do it as a hobby for a while just to
get your feet wet it's another thing
listen knowledge is power ayako
yeah baby iacocca said that knowledge is
wow i just i like i like to spread it
out i like like it's the next like
scary thing like is that it's because
it's like wrestling right it's like
you're wrestling this new thing and like
well get good at that too you know and
that's what i want to do i don't want to
just do it a few times i'd like to make
it part of my living lifestyle
how do you get into like just speaking
about doing things that are scary you're
into a lot of different businesses how
did you get how do you get into jiu
jitsu and coffee and not only like a bar
and well jujitsu is different i got into
jiu jitsu to stop my head and i just
wanted to uh
like i i just wanna i there was always a
thing in my in my body i think where i
was like i wanna
be able to use this i wanna be able to
be useful at it or whatever and like
when i had the chance to jiu jitsu
fascinated me because i got armbar by a
dude that was 100 pounds lighter than me
three times in under a minute
same arm and i was baffled i had no idea
how that happened like because i thought
i was tough right
and so then i just dove into it and i
was i got in there through stick fights
through a group um you know you did kali
uh it's like kali escrima crabby cabron
yeah no holding bar
yeah yeah right because somebody said
you were friends you're one of them i
don't know yeah yeah the one of the [ __ ]
well it's a couple of the founders i'm
good friends that's a crayon
he was saying that
alberto was telling me that there was he
was asked he knows one of the guys had a
belly
he goes one of the guys had a belly and
whenever he did jiu jitsu he had a move
that he would just [ __ ] put it on you
yeah yeah yeah yeah i think i think i
don't know if that's your story that's a
guy in brazil he was telling me he goes
joey the guy tapped everybody with his
belly he goes i was the only guy he
never tapped out do you know why he was
cause i used to make like a straw in my
mouth
[Music]
he'll find an opening he's not tapping
me up yeah
he's not typing me out he goes but the
guy would but he was saying something
about the dog brothers that you know
there was a guy there that was heavy
yeah ireland and he wouldn't move a lot
but he had a move i forgot what he had a
couple he had a couple moves that he
would do and if and if you could
withstand it
he didn't have error to last for the
next few minutes and so you just you
just had to withstand the storm it's
like it was like fighting a really good
wrestler like real good wrestler ain't
gonna finish you
but he's gonna beat your ass all the way
up until you get to choke him but you
get to choke him
you know like and that was like that
like that's it's like real you know real
strong guys without the wind is
that's trouble for them if you can
withstand that and you've got that big
that's a lot of air yeah that's a lot of
air i see these guys that go into the
ufc with tons of muscle and by the
second round they're huffing and puffing
you got to shave away at that muscle a
little bit something something to get
the air in there those muscles we got to
train require a lot of oxygen to [ __ ]
work man my friend uh my friend
he owns a gracie baja now in albuquerque
but
um don ortega and he'd say just because
you're buff don't mean you're tough like
when all these steroid guys would walk
into the gym or something and they'd all
get strangled it's just whatever you're
training you know whatever you're good
at it's not just technique you got to be
in the fire and be underneath the
suffering of somebody else on top of you
trying to strangle the life out of you
and that's where you grow and you can't
grow like that anywhere else than in
those conditions i don't know when
people get involved in different things
whether it be stand-up or fighting or
or
whatever painting or yeah just wanting
to tell us that
like the internal suffering that you
have it's just weird you know you said
it best before the universe we never
think about the universe
when you wake up in the morning you look
out the window the stars we never think
about the universe not the [ __ ]
universe that they talk about in
armageddon
the universe the spiritual
universe
you know
goal writing
let's talk about goal writing kid came
to the show last friday because before i
listen to your podcast i never wrote a
goal in my life why because i started
writing goals and pretty soon they
started coming up
that's because you put something into
the universe yeah you project you know
when i call you the first year of your
standup career i would never call you
and say this to you but there's a lot of
people who call you and go tate what are
you doing tonight nothing come on down
do 15 minutes in front of 400 people
you know
you think you're not going to get paid
you know i'm saying like i would pay you
but then
but it's not about the money
it's about you going down there right
because you just put something into the
universe
whether you bomb or not you don't know
what you're doing right you have no idea
what you just did yep you did something
from the kindness of your soul that
two people gonna laugh that means you
made two people out of the 400 lap
they're gonna think your goofy ass is
funny after two weeks of doing comedy
there always is
and
you know people
don't want to put things into the
universe anymore and before the universe
gives you something back the universe
you and i live in because we believe in
karma we've done time we've done drugs
and we've seen all the you know when you
hit somebody in the head to take 30
dollars
and all of a sudden two weeks later
you got 32 dollars and you lose it when
you jump into the water and you're right
and you remember the 30 you stole two
weeks later the universe gives you
signals that's why i was always scared
that the other shoe was going to drop
it's because i was always forcing the
other shoe to drop i would make it go
i'd make an action that there was for
sure going to be a reaction to a couple
weeks later and maybe i'd be dumb enough
to not be able to see the scope of the
whole reaction like that there were
related issues they're the same issue
yeah man for sure the universe is a very
well you know with stand-up county with
acting
it's a very is that that's
indica
it's a this is from gino do you prefer
indica or do you prefer sativa if you
have a certain type of sativa that'll
sizzle my eyeballs i'll smoke it but
that jack carrera and all that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] don't do nothing uncle joey
we brought a sativa in a haircut you
don't get high on it not at all what
about you
uh i can i i it it's not the same though
i prefer the indica it's uh we're in the
community yeah it's probably just
because that's all i've smoked with joey
for years right because
i i actually i do and i did enjoy the
one because he got me a seat a sativa
once from perennial and he told me to
smoke it before i did some work and i
actually saw the benefits of it i was
like oh yeah i could see that happening
but i i i still prefer indicus
interesting i get the benefit from
whether i smoke and eat it anything that
calms me down
and lets me settle on one thing yeah
they say the sativa is like more of a
encourager
or whatever more of an it gets you high
but it gets you motivated not motivated
it gives you energy that's what people
say say they like sativas i get energy
from an indica yeah me too i get energy
from the thought pattern
the thought pattern the fur you know
i i i don't sit down after i smoke weed
like that [ __ ] about sitting and
watching movies right that was when i
was 22. that that that now
i get high to work
not really stand up but everything that
goes with standard you know dealing with
this the podcast writing jokes
when i write my book when i'm writing a
couple paragraphs in the book right now
with somebody
i have an agent yeah but i'm pretty much
writing it alone at this point and i've
been really really on it and i'm really
proud of myself how do you do it do you
say i'm gonna write three hours in the
morning no matter what or only one
inspired or how do you keep the ambition
to do it going first off i start with
writing a sentence a week
a friend of mine i used to listen to the
podcast said i would just want you to
start with a sentence a week
and two or three times that fail a
certain a sentence a day
a sentence a day i'm sorry
and i failed like two or [ __ ] three
times a sentence a day i would do four
days
but i would still do it you know but
four days since i go to jiu jitsu once a
week for two years nothing ain't really
gonna happen right because by the time
you go there next monday you forgot
about what you learned the week before
you only got four rows the week before
so after while i was writing the special
this year i got that thing
where you know again if you want
something to happen you got to sit there
for two hours and really write and
really think and
i don't sit there and waste that energy
no more
all right so i've said this a thousand
times
when you first start writing you're
gonna go okay uh
uh immigration
i heard chinese people got immigrated
okay
okay so what are you gonna do
so for three [ __ ] hours you're gonna
like this at the coffee shop
i'm sitting with the pen between my
think my teeth making believe i'm
thinking right this is what happens you
just wasted three hours [ __ ] that
write this but i want you to exercise i
want you to write a story about the
first time you went to rehab
that's it joey but what
because you're working that muscle yeah
you're working that muscle this is a
muscle this is a muscle
believe it or not this is a muscle
but the real muscle is sitting your ass
in the chair
that's the muscle we all lack is
actually sitting down for that hour
going mitch hedberg did it every day if
you called mitch hepburn at 11 o'clock
you wouldn't get an answer
from nine to twelve he shut everything
off his house was empty
his window was open he was pointed north
and he [ __ ] wrote you know getting
divine intervention yeah sometimes
people uh
you know they have the certain pattern
to write i've read about a lot of
authors and some of them have
the certainty yeah having their way head
away
everybody has a certain way but
if you have a way it's sitting down and
doing that [ __ ] way and doing it
right i think everybody's looking for
magic right yeah they're looking for a
light switch to go off but nobody wants
to sit there long enough there's no
[ __ ] light switch there's just you in
this [ __ ] office
because this is a small off good so
you're go you're going to go outside no
you got to leave the window open and you
want to fight your left so you farted in
here and you fought it in here that's a
tape i wish i did oh [ __ ] leaf i
didn't fart don't worry somebody [ __ ]
fought it
remember i would fart though and blame
you and no but everybody knew it wasn't
me because you had that protein [ __ ]
i had cocaine farts
you had you had whey protein for it that
fart is a whey protein fart what's it
called mixed with that [ __ ] coffee
and [ __ ]
not maybe whey protein farts it's
disgusting it was the worst the worst
was there we i went into a 7-eleven with
eddie bravo and he would hunt for stuff
that had warnings on it and he'd say eat
this tate and it would be
it'd be like certain sweeteners that had
some [ __ ] in it that was horri
i can't think of the [ __ ] worst thing
ever but they were the worst they were
the worst [ __ ] texas and we're at the
barns and [ __ ] nobles on the
second floor
and we're all sitting in chairs
and i cut a fart in that [ __ ]
that the whole place heard it and we all
got up and walked out of buns and like
gentlemen like gentlemen
i
blasted a fart in there that was a loud
one see i was good for loud ones the
stinky ones you were the [ __ ] most
horrible and he would open the door the
window come back two hours later and you
could still smell the
this the intestine of the frog yeah like
the middle of the fart like if you take
a piece of [ __ ] and cut it in half
it smells completely different like once
you cut this that's it when you're
walking down the street sure
sure it does
how many times you go to the bathroom
and you take a poop and your ship breaks
in half and also like a real skunk comes
up
like one piece is so heavy on the it's
like a metal it's like a steel bat like
one this is real heavy it just breaks
when it's in your muffin you still got
three
and it releases that batman [ __ ]
smoke out of there horrible oh we got to
get more fiber in that life no i always
eat more fiber that's why i don't fart
like do you still do the green stuff
which one
protein drink no like just as just
greens
i eat salads is there some green thing
that you're like yeah i was drinking or
something like that yeah yeah terrible
terrible god they all taste bad they all
taste [ __ ] bad
i dope up every protein powder i get
yeah all of them taste like that i don't
eat any of them i don't know what all
that [ __ ]
like i do like amino acids sometimes but
i don't sell like i eat food like in
that like i don't really [ __ ] with
protein powders sometimes i'll do like a
recovery one a friend of mine makes it's
nice but most of them give you gut
problems like most of them are filled
with some kind of
crazy isolate that is [ __ ] up and
makes your guts all bloated or twit and
i just i'm like i don't like it man it
doesn't make me feel good and i don't
think it has a benefit i think we've
been sold a big bill of goods about like
how much protein like i think the
supplement companies are really like
probably supplement companies make oh
dude a ton of money you know that's my
next business supplement sure why not i
got a great endurance one i got [ __ ]
some good amino all natural all natural
flavors because all of them got cancer
in them and so we've got natural
sweeteners natural flavors all that kind
of stuff in them uh would be out in a
couple months
but yeah man like i don't know like you
asked about like i wouldn't do any of
them businesses i want to do any other
stuff i don't look at it and go here's
the plan i'm gonna take i throw my hat
over the fence and then i gotta crawl
over the fence to get my hat and i think
that's how you get stuff done sometimes
is because if i knew all the work that
went into making like caveman coffee or
pirate life podcast or any like i
wouldn't [ __ ] do it i want to take
that on i want to take all the headaches
and the emotional stuff and the
[ __ ] try to get everybody's uh
character and personalities together
it's a lot but it's also then the thing
that you built that you love and that
you take care of like a baby and you're
like this is a [ __ ] cool thing that i
have thought i've thought the idea into
the universe like and made a thing like
it's so it's kind of dope too it's in
because i have the exact right now i'm
going through a period where i'm trying
to get
as much out as possible so i can focus
on only a couple things well you're
going to need to get an assistant
well no i don't mind i don't need an
assistant now that you've gone into
these six digits i know where you're at
lee i know where you're at
one day but if if if i get in this i
should talk about it kill me
we don't need no [ __ ] assistant
that's the problem in this town is
everybody needs a [ __ ] assistant
at the end of the week
you can get yourself an intern i went
over on that uh that that calms deal and
brendan and um
they got interns and i'm like what's the
intern they're like they do all the work
and we don't like it's like i mean it's
like i was like that's amazing like
they're like yeah it's [ __ ] great
people are just learning the business
are learning this and that and they do
all the work wow
but my thing that would break my heart
with that i like people i like working
with people
and
i would hate for that person to go you
know what this don't serve me anymore so
[ __ ] this i'm not doing this either like
i would only want those positions to
segue into something where pretty soon
you can be driving a bmw you know what i
mean like i wanna
that's that that's the whole point of
the internship that's a whole
i mean it's tough when you're in school
because if you're in school you can't
get a job but
when you're a senior when you're a
senior
like that's the hope is you'll intern
there and then get a get a job offer i
don't want anybody in here working for
free number one
not even in
i don't want anybody working for free
and number two i don't want nobody in
here
that's the beauty box that could be
number one i don't want nobody in i
don't want nobody
where's this guy that's san lazaro
he's a saint of the dogs and [ __ ] those
are the people that we're gonna kill
michael vick that's why i didn't let him
in a lot of federal prisons
cubans are real big in san lazaro so
that's like so that's like saint francis
also like the the patron saint animals
right yeah so
but these guys go a little deeper
they'll stab you and shoot you over
[ __ ] dogs yeah because the dogs
licked lazarus's legs and they licked
his whatever disease he had i can't
think about it right now anyway
but uh
yeah just
same [ __ ] uh
he's kind of well i'm sure he was built
he was 90 pounds he was a [ __ ] bone
and muscle you know that was [ __ ] it
no it's you know lee wants to start
businesses what kind of businesses i'm
not that's the thing is we've been
talking about it and i have a few
different ideas on going back and forth
between but then also
part of me if i'm being honest is this i
would love to do this for as long as it
as i possibly can take whatever i make
go live in vegas and not deal with
anybody anymore i just play play cards
he wants to play be a professional
gambler so i tell him that he got the
books and he goes to gamble three four
days a week crazy if that's what he
wants to do and who knows like i could
always i could always do something it's
i never thought like what you saying
with all the businesses you've done i
never thought i'd be here so i could
i in in six years i could be in alabama
doing something who knows but
right now it makes me happy like that's
that's when i i see you a lot on
instagram
and like i'm
i hate i really do i really don't like
when people tell me
that oh it's work it's not going to be
fun i i really i don't
i don't want to live my life like
something that's not fun yeah i don't
want to i would pick the things you love
lee right and i love this and
and you know what it's it's a huge it's
a huge gamble it's a huge risk but
that's
the most fun i have when i was i was
thinking about it the other night i was
like when do i actually have fun
because joe joey gets mad at me he's
like i stay home i don't i don't like a
lot of 100 years old i don't like a lot
but what i like when he moves his
girlfriend and now they really stay home
too every night a week yeah you know she
don't want to do nothing she has to work
at 8 in the morning so that puts him and
it's like they can get away from each
other they got like one room so i'm like
you gotta get out of the [ __ ] house
if not you're gonna end up stabbing a
[ __ ] and i i love casinos when
people say they don't like vegas i don't
get it there's i love everything about
it i even i've never smoked i smoked one
cigarette in my life in jordan from a
cab driver but that's it that's it i
love when people smoke at the tables i
love the smell of cigarettes i love i
love drink i love i don't drink i drink
every time i go to the casino i take two
stars two red stars which does nothing
to me but it just calms me down a little
bit
and i have the best time ever if i
the the thing i've actually started
doing now though is i set a timer
because i'll sit at the table all day
because i love it and that's when you
lose your money so i started saying like
30 minutes and 45 minute timers to see
where i am and like take a break
but uh yeah that's if i if i really sit
down and think about it i love
everything about casinos and i know most
people hate it and it's it's a lot to
degenerate but
i that some of the best people that i
meet and get to talk to and we're
high-fiving and telling stories
is people at blackjack tables i think
that everybody should have a job
and then a journey you know everybody
sure so you don't want to be keep
getting fallen down now in five years
you'll be producing films yeah the
studios yeah the progression their
studios in santa fe in three years
you're going to go you know what i don't
want to call here he's on borrowing me
again i'm done with this [ __ ] i'll
[ __ ] kick him in the stomach and end
it from
i'm saying how many times can piano
reeves [ __ ] choke me out [ __ ] him
yeah so one day you go [ __ ] this [ __ ]
and
everybody evolves man but at the end of
the day
it's a journey i was telling you when
you came in you asked me and i told you
the [ __ ] truth
and i always had natural aptitude right
and i can always make a buck like
growing up i always knew how to make a
buck from [ __ ] day one i knew
so
you know when i was
27 i was
[ __ ] frustrated
i was frustrated you know i was making
before i got locked up the year and a
half before i got left i was making
anywhere from three
to seven thousand dollars a month in
those days my rent was 450. i had four
roommates in boulder you know i'm saying
i'm making four or five thousand dollars
a month and i'm spending 700 a month at
the house the rest was on blow yeah dry
cleaning
and booze
i would get high and at two in the
morning i'd knock on the roommate's door
and give her a stab and eat a position
and then go back to my room like nothing
happened you know what i'm saying
the specter you know but
it was so [ __ ] weird how i started
making that money like i i was making
800 a [ __ ] month
washing cars and they asked me to start
selling cars and one day i went from the
first day i sold cars i made a thousand
dollars and i was like call the detail
shopping i'm never coming back
what you guys were paying me in a month
i made it in one [ __ ] day
every month after i was brand new
subaru's in boulder come on guys yeah
yeah yeah unless you're [ __ ] you're
not gonna make [ __ ] no money and
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know
i ran into one of the best salesmen ever
today like we were just sitting i i was
taking those stupid pictures but we're
just sitting up there and the guy from
the sprint store came out and was like
you know what really make your
your pictures look really good an iphone
7s from sprint
and then he started going he's like you
know what i can see your life is on your
phone like he just started going at me
and joe perez for like five minutes he
[ __ ] up
why he ain't the best salesman in the
world
because me i would have gone out there
with the camera and taking pictures
ah
don't bro see what i'm saying god damn
that's where the amateurs [ __ ] fail
and right there i would have had you
outside with numbers what are you paying
for that right now
let me do this have you seen the
commercial right there you selling your
feet and your clothes on your ass you
understand me i wouldn't have [ __ ]
told you that would have been work work
better i would have came out with the
phone taking the [ __ ] picture and
then showed it to you in competition and
now i got you
i got my hooks in here let's go in maybe
you have a sprint phone i get your two
phones for the price of one it's
wednesday
now i got you and joe perez all [ __ ]
up
my job as a salesman is to keep you
[ __ ] up yeah keep you interested keep
you [ __ ] up i just think as long as i
could get like i used to sell roofs and
uh and like siding and [ __ ] and uh and
we saw in denver would do storms
storms
yeah
and i go man
if i'm sitting on the couch having a
glass of water i got a contract and so
that would be my only goal i want to try
to sell the ho i want to i would just go
i'm just trying to get on that couch
if i can get welcomed in their home make
them feel comfortable i'm good i'm good
yeah listen uh leave your card we got
your estimate and we'll call you back in
the week and within three days they call
you back or sometimes
that day you leave with a [ __ ]
deposit i love
selling roofs it was fun man selling
roofs was the
something i did for about 18 months that
was keeping me from shooting
[ __ ]
okay it was my tail end couple of last
months
in the halfway house i got out of there
but i was still on community corrections
and i had two brother-in-laws
that were
you know they were like i hate to say
this
but they were like acclaimed roofers
like all day long people would [ __ ]
come on the roof and go listen we got
this roof over on federal
and this and this and they knew it they
had been doing it for the same company
since they were 16 years old
and now they were both in their [ __ ]
mid-30s and they knew everything i mean
our crew in those days we did a
a ballasted roof when you do rocks on it
yeah but you have to we would do 40
square a day two roof tear up
lay down insulation
five of us it was unheard of but they
were geniuses they knew
like was seven to three thirty they
didn't believe in overtime and people go
how the [ __ ] do you do this every day
the rock came at three
while we were doing stone those two
animals would be flashing they didn't
believe in overtime they wouldn't pay it
and they wouldn't work it crazy so
everything they did was buy the [ __ ]
eyeball
it was the most brilliant toot but they
were socially the one guy they called
him the prowler
because he wouldn't go home
huh my old brother-in-law tom was a
great guy
but i think he still has the record in
colorado for duis wow like 18 or
something like somebody told me three
years ago i talked i still talked to one
of the roofers i was partners with and
he goes yeah and the other guy
was genius material but had no social
skills right but he would go on a roof
he would buy a quarter pound of weed and
smoke in a week
because he would real he would bring a
bong and his jacket in the winter
but it was the craziest thing i ever saw
my ex brother-in-law's mike's
brother-in-law's a dynamite
[ __ ] you ever talk to any of
them again
no or the x or nothing like that
i called the ex two years ago
i had the baby the baby was two years
you know and i called the ex and i said
listen this was going on
you know we're squared up
what do we need to do for me to talk to
my daughter she goes uh
she's still upset about grandfather and
her and her boyfriend broke up shakoy in
a few days that was two years ago yeah i
called her back asked her
again didn't have an answer
so i'm still on the fence on that
decision
um
you know i mean i don't talk to my ex
any things i mean nothing that
relationship ended 20 years ago right
when i almost got him thrown off a roof
in jersey because
the wife was busting my ex-wife was
busting my balls
so for me to flex my muscles they were
they were they had a roofing company in
jersey
but they were using like non-union
roofing so i called a friend of mine to
rough him up a little bit go up on the
roof and tell him you had to take the
[ __ ]
that really decapitated me with the
family there's one brother-in-law
that he's from jersey and he's tight
that [ __ ] still hasn't friended
me back on
on facebook there's still a friend
request sent
from like every year he says no yeah
just hanging around there i was nope not
today [ __ ] joey when i got out
of that when i got out of that marriage
it sent ripples through and i feel bad
because her parents are really nice
people and they're very good to me so i
i think about them all the time in fact
in uh
in that [ __ ] movie the accountant
that the the guy's name was ray king oh
yeah that was his name right king they
were very good to me man so
i always feel guilty about that i still
have
my anger issues about the ex-wife right
because
there's some issues that people have for
them there's some issues that people
have right i was raised not to let
somebody have the better half of you you
know she pretty much yanked that kid
from me
[Music]
what have i done
you know what i am sure 20 years ago
they would have been in the [ __ ] hole
but my goal to be honest was to come out
here and if [ __ ] didn't work out on the
way back east i was going to stop over
there and stab them both i mean that was
the plan at that point if you're going
to go go deep
i hope we've all learned something from
pablo escobar he blew up a plane okay
you want to [ __ ] with me i'll blow up a
[ __ ] plane but look what happened to
him and you're still here yeah but
uh
the the situation was that's how angry i
was i'm not getting angry no more
you know what man
who knows what would happen between me
and my daughter now who the [ __ ] knows
you know who the [ __ ] knows
it's been god knows since i talked to
her there's some stuff man it's like
that's the thing is like that's either a
stopping point or a starting point and i
was talking to a friend last night and
like uh
talking about like uh do you ever still
be like ashamed of the ways that you've
been or ways of being or et cetera et
cetera and i go i go i go no i go but
you know there's there's some stuff that
you just got to live with there's some
stuff you can't make better you could
just be more available be better suited
to be helpful if you could be helpful
but there's some [ __ ] that [ __ ] your
pennant like that that whole thing i go
you know you're not you're not punished
for the sin
at some certain [ __ ] date there ain't
no judgment day man
you're punished by the sin right now by
doing it when your awareness pops and
your consciousness rises you're at a
point where
the thing tortures you and that's why
you don't act those ways and like and
and some stuff you just got to swallow
and you got to live with it
and and then and then i think you know i
think the same thing would just be a i
tell myself six days a week that
i'm gonna swallow it and live with this
my dna
will never allow it
you know i'm saying
like nietzsche said a man without a plan
is not a man
i'm in no danger of dying in a prison
nor do i want to
i have finally normalized my life this
november
i did the biggest goal of my life
because i thought i got off that white
[ __ ] devil yeah something i did for
37 of my 54 [ __ ] years
and did it well and did it constantly
and did it with no
i didn't give a [ __ ] that's what i want
you know when i got you're one of those
i only know a couple of guys like you
like maybe two
that
they go so deep
with a powder
that
there ain't no skinny fat like that
they're the heaviest dudes that i'd
known
like weight wise like poundage like 400
pounders
and they would do coke they would eat a
plate of spaghetti and i was like i
don't like i'm i'm watching something i
think is physically impossible and
you're one of those guys man like it's i
can never do coke and eat but the
metabolism changes to where you can keep
the weight come on and be doing powder
at the same time by the boat level i
didn't do powder in the my my
the the thing that saved me for years
was i was never a daytime guy huh i was
not a daytime guy i wasn't a bumper all
day
somebody had that wrong i was like a
salesman or something right those are
new year those are car salesmen [ __ ]
yeah if if in 37 years okay in 37 years
if i did coke 25 times in the daytime
it was it meant that i couldn't wait
like i was the type of person that and a
man was going all night
oh yeah then if it weren't for the night
before that's something completely i
don't care right right i'm talking about
i worked with guys like rob daniel i
worked with this guy
that would get into work with a lunch
box
with bags under his eyes he would sleep
all night but from seven to four when he
was doing construction
it was straight on
it was something that i had never seen
before right you know it was like in the
70s when you'd watch tv and i came to
your office first thing you did without
even asking was turn around no you
didn't offer you put two ice cubes in
the glass you board and you gave it to
me there was no offer and i wouldn't say
no not today i drank the [ __ ] thing
you know i knew people that were doing
coke
all day long number two
again this is what i never understood
i started comedy july 18th in 1991 saint
patty's day
1992 i did a show with troy baxley and
to be the cool emcee i brought a grandma
blow
didn't work out for me
never did blow and went on stage
i did blow the night before i went on
stage now if you do blow three nights in
a row and you go on stage you're not
gonna be you big difference but i never
sat in a comedy store
and got on stage right that never
happened because there's no
you'd wait to get a package after
something the package would be in my
pocket burning a hole that [ __ ]
yeah if you don't remember that in
between the room
the green room with joe rogan that in
between i couldn't wait till the second
show started yeah because i would bring
joe up and i wouldn't even say goodbye
to you [ __ ] bye it's not even no
there was no goodbye where'd joey go
yeah and then you guys would text me
page me and there was no calling nobody
back not once got a text back
nothing nothing you're in no danger when
i was snorting and i was on my way well
maybe we'll see him on the plane i guess
on the way back yeah he would knock on
the door on the way down joey you coming
yeah and i'd be clean yeah i wouldn't be
you know sometimes i'd stop snoring at
two and we would get on the plane at
like nine
or something like that i'd stop snoring
at six in the morning we were gonna plan
at 11 there were those situations but it
was so weird how the
i was always a nighttime guy at eight
o'clock on the way to the store i would
pick it up put it in my pocket in my
right top pocket
i would dangle i would dangle i would
talk to you the whole time
i'd just be looking at you but thinking
what is this [ __ ] gonna get out
of my face right so i could get on stage
and do this [ __ ] spot because once i
do that spot i'm coming right out here
and i'm doing the line and i'm going to
go into that bar and get a drink and
that's the rest of my [ __ ] night
and guess what [ __ ] lee gave me the
40 he owed me so i'm going to buy
another two packages i mean that was my
life date that was my wife who am i
kidding yeah
so it was
for me to think about november 8th of
this year
and think to myself it was 10 years
since i last did a line of coke
something that i would snort when i was
when i first got into comedy i made
myself a deal i said if i'm gonna do
this
the other thing i'm not gonna wrestle
with
is this cocaine decision
i'm not gonna do that tape
i did a year of that
all right guys tonight's my last night
of cocaine guys this is it no and i
wouldn't even snort with people at the
end i would say it to myself this is the
last night i never did that there was a
day i looked at myself in the mirror and
said
i'm a junkie
this is who i am
and this is what i'm going to do
i know i can't snort seven days a week
but i'm gonna go i'm gonna give the yo
yankee try i'm going for three nights
and that's what i did i was very content
doing coke three four nights a week and
sleeping three nights i was very content
because i knew that's what i was gonna
do yeah i wasn't gonna wrestle with it
no more
the only time i wrestled with it was my
last two years
that was the worst ever that was the
worst when i knew it had to stop
for many reasons it had to stop for the
comedy
it had to stop for my relationship
it had to stop from my heart and how to
stop the sleep apnea it just had to stop
there was no
towards the end the last maybe nine
months
i was getting electroshocks in my spine
in the middle of night that's when you
know
it's not good
crazy i'm talking
like just out of the blue
no [ __ ] yeah no no no no and then it
started getting upper and higher and
higher and at one point i started
feeling electricity in my [ __ ] neck
and i think it was two months after that
i had a sharp pain
right over here nobody would argue you
were healthy oh no remember when that
other head was growing over your
shoulder
the [ __ ] was that that was a [ __ ] fat
ball
so he said that it was really [ __ ]
got the same science today it was a fat
ball that's all it was it was a fat a
ball of fat
that wasn't tumor or cancer
did you get it checked out ever yeah i
gotta take them out okay i didn't know
i'll take it out yeah i don't know if it
just went away and it wasn't poor when
you have sleep apnea your body goes into
shock at night when you can't breathe so
all this cortisol is released into your
body at night and that's why when you
see people over 300 pounds 350
there's a point where you could go up to
them you don't even need to be a
neurosurgeon or a doctor at that point
you go up to them tap them on the back
and go
you got about six months before this
stroke happens and it's all downhill
after that it's a life of misery
you get that fat developing around
this region
you see it a lot of people in the
midwest
you go to texas you see big guys but
they have a little ball that's where the
uh
that thing
gets
compacted when you see people they gotta
turn that back once that hunch starts
coming and they're about 360 they
definitely got sleep apnea that's why
they got the hunch
the hump because the the cortisol
develops right there and that's why when
you see people over 400 pounds
that that that [ __ ] slunching that's
just a ball of cortisol and to really
separate that you got to stop putting
your body into this danger it's got to
be you know every time
you choke at night your body's in
[ __ ] danger so you think they're
curing your sleep apnea that settled out
a lot of stuff well when you don't sleep
you know people think you don't ever
recover there's no no i only slept four
hours last night but
you're not recovering you don't recover
so not only does it throw off your
glands and all but it throws off your
metabolism right so you don't burn off
as much fat
uh
in
april
or march of 2000 of night of 2000 a
friend of mine got a deal and
i got an audition for a mobster and i
had no money and i contacted him and i
said listen i'm gonna bind
i got a great opportunity for a
commercial but i don't have a suit to
wear
and he took me and bought me three suits
in march of 2000 beautiful suits
tailored because he used to be a suit
guy that was your thing no no i'm a
mobster
i'm a mobster i don't wanna you know you
gotta wear different looks when you go
for a commercial and you go for a mob
commercial you got to wear a white shirt
but when you go for a movie or a tv show
and you're a mobster you can wear any
other color shirt there was different
things but that's not the point of the
story the point of the story tate was
like
again you're my brother
in
march he bought me three suits
in may
tailored suit
tailored suit all three pants no nobody
takes this to the laundry right i gained
such an amount of weight then in may
they were three inches away
wow like i did i was so embarrassed to
take him back to the tailor because he
was gonna go what happened
there was a point where i went from zero
to sixty like i went from
lurking at
285
to 360.
crazy like just
a month six weeks 20 60 at that point in
my life i was doing coke four or five
nights a week i was smoking cigarettes
yeah i was drinking sodas
and there was no sleep the sleep apnea
wouldn't let me sleep the fear had
intimidated me so much that i would take
five or six i'd started with four town
rpms
and let's say i would lay down at 12 15
by 1 15 the sleep apnea would wake me up
and i would just stay up the rest of the
night [ __ ] on those tylenol pms i'd go
call for a grandma blow
eat some anxiety medication [ __ ]
oh yeah
my wife you come over [ __ ] towards my
wife you tell my
the one of the first things i had to do
was pay for a carpet
in that first apartment because i kept
falling asleep at night with cigarettes
in my hand
my wife would wake up every night
kicking
a cigarette turning it off in the carpet
the whole carpet was filled with
cigarette burns you thought a junkie
lived there he did but not a heroin
junkie
i was a coke junkie that could not sleep
at night
from
the town rpms so i would not out and
then wake up
and in those days tate
i was smoking two packs of cigarettes a
day
and then i'd buy three packs of camel
lights at night and i wouldn't go to bed
those three packs of camel lights were
gone holy [ __ ]
oh we could when you saw that picture at
the i remember during the longest show
when i met you you brought me oxygen
to put my sleep apnea machine that the
doctor would come in every day we'd have
to force the documentation
because the producers told them if my
blood pressure was ever high in a
certain amount i wasn't allowed to
[ __ ] be in that movie so that guy
would sit with me for an hour every day
that poor uh do you remember that guy
that's how bad a shape i was in during
the longest yard yeah i met you i was
like he might die this evening
i mean you're over there you're i
remember the first time we ever talked
you're on a picnic table you're rapping
[ __ ] ready to die or something
and now you're wrapping a whole album
and uh
and then that who played that [ __ ] was
over there tracy morgan was raised
the whole time he followed me like a
sabbath
and then like you
and heather brought me the chlorogen and
stuff well the oxygen i started putting
that because it was a high altitude i
was a mess 90 degrees
[ __ ] 100 degrees 7 000 feet altitude
we
an easy 350
at that time 390. yeah by the time the
movie wrapped i was about 4 15. those
pastrami sandwiches were a [ __ ]
once we got up here they were
[ __ ]
that was uh uh not very good tell them
they remember going to the ymca
getting on the scale they gave you a
free evaluation when you joined
and the guy put the scale on point five
and i couldn't do two minutes
on the treadmill
i couldn't walk two minutes on the
treadmill the guy told me i had to go
get in shape outside he goes i
he goes how do you live you can't even
breathe
it's a brighter day man it's a brighter
day we're very lucky so it's going to be
10 years that's as far as i'm concerned
i've been sober for 10 years i've done
more in 10 years
than i did in 37. is that amazing
like that like that's what always trips
me out when i look at like
doing what seems like the hard thing or
the frustrating thing and i'm like well
my life rocketed after that you know and
you always knew it [ __ ] you always knew
it why you had that syringe in your arm
or that line of code
or you were taking that pill you always
knew that you were like you said just
sit down and write
you know when you just finally do it and
sit down and you're like oh beauty comes
out of this pen
it was something that it was like a
living in a [ __ ] living hell like i
made a decision when i was 16 or 17 i
wanted to do coke and somebody said okay
you want to do coke i'm going to give
you [ __ ] coke because i couldn't get
away from it
like there was five years there where
everywhere like if tate said to me are
you coming to new mexico stay at my
friend eddie's house okay eddie's
coolest [ __ ] but guess what his roommate
did for a good job so blow that was my
life
i could bump into cocaine on mars you
know i was one of those guys not heroin
not speed i could find cocaine
[ __ ] anywhere within two minutes
anywhere i moved there was a cocaine
dealer somewhere around there that was i
i always knew it one time i actually
moved with a guy before i got sentenced
the guy when i left that apartment where
i got picked up i moved with a roommate
and i'm noticing i'm sitting there one
day
and people coming over there
but yeah joey this is tate how you doing
tate's profile how you know some 15
minutes later another guy would come
over
and then that night i go up to my room
and i come back at 10 and
two people had just left
and then i would wake up at three to
drink water and he'd be up
after downstairs a week i figured out oh
my god this guy sells [ __ ] blow so
i'm about to get sentenced for doing
blow right and i'm moving with a drug
dealer it's from my neighborhood just 20
years old i went to the vietnam war
and it got to the point where every
night i would watch him watching tv and
i would open up his closet and i'd go in
his jacket pocket
and i'd take out the ounce he would
bring up only and i'd take a rock out
put it back in his pocket that's how
easy it got like this could only happen
to me
like this could only happen to me not
only do i move him with a drug dealer
but i know where his stash is right that
was the little stash yeah his big stash
was in the garage and paint cans
that's where he would put the kilos and
break them up into four different paint
cans
but he would do that he was a freebaser
so this is where it gets even worse i
would monitor him completely like i knew
when the guy came with the package i
knew when the cash was going out because
the cash
it was all run through a bodybuilding
gym in acapulco mexico
oh my god you have no idea crazy so this
guy his father was a doctor physical
trainer
and supposedly he would come up here
with prescriptions and things right but
hidden in those prescriptions was 20
kilos of blow
and he would do that every [ __ ] month
except for the summer months
because that's when that part of mexico
would be busy or the winter months
so for six months
he would ship him like
what do you get rid of a month a kilo
okay so every month i'm gonna give you
two kilos you don't have to pay me for
one but then once comes uh november
you're not gonna see me till june right
so when i come back you better have my
money for the six kilos so there was a
time when i'd be living upstairs and
downstairs there'd be six kilos
[ __ ] wild so then i would watch him
and like i'd hear him freebasing by this
time the cat was out of the bag i knew
what he did i kept playing it off like i
didn't do coke
like i did coke once in a while he
thought i was like an athlete
so i would wait for him to start
freebasing
he would go through that whole back so i
would have listened for him
i would get up at like six in the
morning and if i would go on his jacket
my jacket pocket was empty that means he
had gone through that bag and he broke
into the kilo
so i would
my car was out in front of the garage
so i would come down open up the garage
he'd be in there free basin and i'd find
the can because the can would be sloppy
and i'd open up that can and at this
point i just stick my hand down and i
just pull out a [ __ ] boulder
and i take it with me and i break it up
at the hurts place and i'd sell it and
that's how i was making a living by
taking his [ __ ] blow disgusting and
stealing and snorting it but i would
come home that night
and he'd be there all depressed
and i go what happened he go
i want a two-bit i want a two-day bender
how am i gonna get this money and i go
what are you talking about he'd go
i did about an ounce and a half a coke
he didn't do another half a cup he did a
half ounce i took an ounce with me yeah
he was so [ __ ] up that he didn't know
yeah i mean it was
but this could only happen to me this
[ __ ] jesus i see the [ __ ] that was
happening everywhere to me like anywhere
i turned to
blow was right i think it's that
vibration yes it is you put out a
cocaine vibration you know that you
brought it in vibrations
like whatever the thing is that
resonates in you the most man that [ __ ]
draws to you and let me tell you
something
that's true it's like nobody ever came
to me and asked me if i want to do
heroin right when you do heroin the
universe makes you bump into heroin
when you do math yeah i've had people
ask me if i want to do math in fact i
bought methods a couple times i couldn't
find coke
yeah
but if that was what till today
gets me weird here's the thing that
killed me about cocaine [ __ ] the cat
that died last year we had it for ten
years
the first
seven years she was around i did coke
she wouldn't even have contact with me
a week after i stopped doing coke she
became my favorite category i couldn't
get her off me
that cocaine energy she felt it as a cat
and she stopped [ __ ] me so
the moral of the story is
cats now if you're doing [ __ ] tootsie
roots
that's the [ __ ] moral of the story
right there
i'm happy [ __ ] got together
here yeah that's it hey listen and
people know
whatever you're doing when you're drunk
on alcohol and you're [ __ ] in a hole
you know what the answer is we all know
it bro sure you know today everybody
what's going on because there's so much
help around there's so many [ __ ] i
mean
find your answers when you want them me
and you bandana me and you were down a
great [ __ ] road
if somebody pulled up to us
with the [ __ ] hand of life we still
turn them down it wasn't until we made
our decision that our lives changed
we got help you know what a dude told me
once i go man i'd love to
all the gifts you got guy i [ __ ] love
and he goes he goes [ __ ] that kid
he goes your gifts are going to be
better because they're going to be yours
and that is the thing man don't don't
ever don't ever want for anybody else's
life man
yours is the one that fits
lee what'd you think of a massage from
zeal you got it a couple days what for
valentine's day yeah uh the weekend the
weekend of valentine's day i had it it
was my first massage ever i never had
one and i was a little nervous and they
sent two of them yeah we got a couple of
them for you for your wife that was
tremendous and would you do it again i
would do it immediately i would do it it
was uh it was a great experience i i
have never i've never been to a spa but
i i really enjoyed having them come to
my place i enjoyed any any want to know
why the the main reason i was i was so
relaxed and so calm after the massage
the thought of getting in my car and
driving yeah 30 minutes after that i was
like i don't i don't want to do that
they do host surf they do like service
to your house they come to you how's
that so [ __ ] tremendous another big
thing which they mentioned which i think
would be great is a hotel that's a big
one that's what i think would be really
great i love to have it at my place but
my place is an apartment so a couple
times i'd hear some people outside but
if i was in like a nice hotel that like
a little setback the room's a little sit
back have them come right to your thing
you get sheets from the concierge or
they can bring sheets
they have they had music they had oil
this uh we had two of them one was a
little bit younger one was a little bit
older i had the older one and
so there's something about me like
i judge people by their if their hands
are warm she had the most warm loving
it was it was the best hour i've ever
had that's awesome you know what the
best thing about that is everybody loves
massages but nobody gets them why
because either the spa is closed or
you're booked when you want one or
trying to get there and sitting in
traffic just destroys your day we're
introducing zeal where you can book a
five star top quality massage at a time
that works for you in the most
convenient place of all your house who's
better than you whether your back hurts
or you're running after the kids or your
muscles are sore zeal brings you the
same day in-home massages with the best
license
and massage therapist right to your home
think again
an in-home massage is something only
available to the rich and famous think
again zeal is the perfect solution for
anyone who wants a high quality massage
in the convenience of their own home if
you want a good massage but you don't
have the time to get one have the
massage come to you with zeal you pick
at the time the location and have your
next massage on demand
at
home you understand me just go to
zeel.com or on zeal's
iphone or android app that's zeal
spelled z-e-e-l
dot-com and select your top local
license and pre-screened massage
therapist choose your favorite technique
gender preference time and location of
your massage
zeal will send one of the 8 000 licensed
massage therapists with a massage table
music and supplies to give you a five
star massage schedule booking payment is
fast and easy seven days a week
365 days a year a zeal massage therapist
can be at your door in as little as an
hour find out for yourself why zeal has
been featured in the wall street journal
new york times vogue and on good morning
america bring the spot to you and zeal
today really today they're on demand you
can have the best massage of your life
in your home with zeal today to help you
get started our listeners get 25 off
their first massage by using the promo
code church
c-h-u-r-c-h at checkout that's zeal
spell z-e-e-l
dot com and then make sure to click add
promo code at checkout to use
my code church c-h-u-r-c-h
right now
go to zeel.com or on zeal's iphone
android app and get a special offer when
you try zeal today enter pro como
promo code church and check out and you
get 25 hours off your phones your first
in-home massage on demand you understand
me give it a shot number two
i've been telling you about these people
for a long time if you don't have one by
now shame on you nobody wants to walk
around with a [ __ ] up looking [ __ ]
let's pretend you're bumping to somebody
and they want to do the new style of the
rusty trombone they're doing in [ __ ]
france right now but your [ __ ] stinks
like 10 dead [ __ ] farts what are you
gonna do then
nothing you can't get that [ __ ] rusty
trombone but now
with tushy
you could get whatever you want done to
your [ __ ] let's pretend next year
[Music]
and you're asking why
because tushy's a bidet hello tushy
bidets are back [ __ ] you know what a
bidet does for you it washes out your
little muffler you and they're portable
you can snap them right to your house
you got a 60-day guarantee if something
goes bad but it won't because nobody's
better than you nobody has better pep in
their step and more confidence when your
[ __ ] is clean you understand me some
people have a car some people find
confidence in different things me myself
if my [ __ ] smells good i'm totally
i'm ready to [ __ ] go now also having
a bidet cleans your muffler from [ __ ]
hemorrhoids it prevents [ __ ] [ __ ]
growing down there plus you can watch
the back of your nut sack and that's
always [ __ ] good right there all
right anytime your genitalia can be
fresh and sparkly you win go to
hellopushy.com right now
press in church c-h-u-r-c-h
get 10 off you understand me and if you
get two you get free shipping one for
her bathroom and one for your bathroom
some guys like to eat [ __ ] fresh if you
do get her a bidet me i like to eat it
after you run two miles not three little
two mile run a little yoga that monkey
got some [ __ ] wang to it you know
what i'm saying not two and a half speak
to me oh toothless one go to
hellotushy.com right now and press in
church
get ten percent off your order you bad
[ __ ] i love you we'll see you
next week and i want to thank
ionic.com right now go to on it right
now and get yourself some of that hemp
force protein the cocoa or
get yourself some shroom tech or get
yourself some new mood it's gonna
[ __ ] help you out go to honda.com and
press in church bam
c-h-u-r-c-h get 10 percent off delivered
to your house who's better than you i
want to thank honor i want to thank zeal
and i want to thank tushy
for [ __ ] sponsoring the podcast
tonight but most importantly i want to
thank you guys do not forget next week
start not next week the week after that
march 16th
ultimate
baltimore [ __ ] i'm coming back get
that crack ready number two
at the end of the month i'm up in nyack
new york and leveling live
3 3 through april [ __ ] first get your
tickets now i want to thank my main tate
fletcher for coming out
yeah yeah drink the [ __ ] coffee yeah
he's got like nine businesses go to his
webpage he'll tell you all yeah check
out my name tate fletcher check out
pirate life podcast pirate life podcast
or caveman coffee or caveman coffee yo
bars massage parlors tate's got it all
you understand
he's got more jobs in the [ __ ]
jamaican i want to thank my main man lee
syed and we'll see you guys on the
lord's day sunday afternoon with a
surprise guest see you next week thank
you for listening stay black you bad
[ __ ]
i'm like an immigrant i got so many jobs
if you don't have 10 jobs you ain't
there
[Music]
you